Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Wir wollen auf die europäischen Top-Ligen zurückblicken, nachdem wir ja schon in dieser Saison besser drauf geguckt haben denn je. Deswegen begrüße ich euch zur Rasenfunk Ligatour. Hallo liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, schön, dass ihr mit dabei seid. Wir wollen heute noch ein letztes Mal für diese Saison 21, 22 auf die Serie A, La Liga, die Premier League und auch die Liga blicken. Und ich freue mich sehr, dass ich jetzt erst mal drei Gäste hier begrüßen darf. Zum einen Joachim Hebel von Sky und der Saunen. Servus Jogi. Ja, schön, dass wir wieder in dieser Runde zusammen sind. Ebenfalls hier ist Marius Soyke, den kennt ihr natürlich von Serie Amore und transfermark.de. Hallo Marius.
Schön, dass ich immer wieder dabei sein kann. Danke für die Einladung.
Das finde ich auch. Es war ein harter Kampf, wer hier in die Saisonfazitfolge darf. Und da hat sich durchgesetzt, bei den Spaniern Alex Truica von barsterwelt.de und als ad Alex Truica natürlich auch auf Twitter. Hallo Alex. Später werden wir auch noch Alexis Menuge hören zur Ligue 1. Die Sendung verläuft jetzt folgendermaßen. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, ihr hört jetzt unser Vierergespräch über die entsprechenden Ligen und hinten dran noch den Teil mit Alexis. Der hat es zeitlich nicht einrichten können, hier dabei zu sein. Aber natürlich wollen wir trotzdem die Liga hier abbilden. Deswegen beginnen wir jetzt mit den ersten drei Ligen. Hinten raus kommt der Alexis und am Ende ist das eine runde Geschichte. Und überzeugt euch ja vielleicht auch davon, den Rasenfunk zu unterstützen. Wir bleiben Werbe-, Paywall- und Sponsoren frei. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich von euren freiwilligen Zahlungen unter rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Da könnt ihr erfahren, wie das geht und auch schon kleine Beträge helfen. Also ein Euro im Monat, zwei Euro im Monat. Das ist hoffentlich für euch drin. Und das sorgt dann nicht nur dafür, dass wir etwas davon haben, Frank und ich, sondern auch unsere Gäste, die ein Honorar bekommen. Und diese Honorare sollen auch weiter wachsen. Also alles, was jetzt neu reinkommt, fließt eigentlich eher so an die Gäste, denn an uns. Und so soll das auch sein im Rasenfunk. Also bitte unterstützt uns. Könnt ihr auch tun, indem ihr unter kiosk.rasenfunk.de merchandise kauft. Und als Hinweis noch, weil wir jetzt hier zurückblicken, wir haben dasselbe auch zur Männe 2. Bundesliga gemacht in der letzten Woche. Und wir tun dasselbe natürlich auch zur 1. Bundesliga, der Männer im Rasenfunk Royale. Der erscheint in der Nacht auf Mittwoch, den 23. 5., Entschuldigung, den 25.5., den 23. haben wir ja heute. Den könnt ihr dann auch hören, einfach die Schlusskonferenz abonnieren. Das soll es jetzt aber gewesen sein, reicht mit der Vorrede. Wir gehen heute mal so ein paar Fragen nacheinander durch, Reihe um. Und die erste davon ist, wie lief denn jetzt das Meisterschaftsrennen am Ende? Und ich würde sagen, Jogi darf an der Stelle mal beginnen. Jogi, überrasch uns. Wer ist Meister geworden in der Premier League? Man hat es ja kaum mitbekommen. Und warum nicht die Konkurrenz?
Ja, also erstmal, ich hatte ja wenigstens ein Meisterschafts-Final in dem Sinne. Aber natürlich ist Manchester City Meister geworden. Und das war wirklich nochmal richtig heftig. Also ich bin reingegangen in das Spiel. Ich hatte das Einzelspiel Liverpool, durfte es mir aussuchen, quasi von Sky, was ich will. Und Uli hat dann City bekommen. Und ich dachte, City gewinnt das Spiel 4-0. Und dann ist die Diskussion vorbei. Ich hatte halt die Hoffnung, dass Liverpool vielleicht, und dass dann natürlich der große Pop entsteht. Und dann geht es in dieses Spiel rein. Und Liverpool liegt nach drei Minuten hinten. Und ich denke mir, das gibt es jetzt nicht. Also ich dachte, die würden ihre Aufgabe wenigstens erfüllen. Und City liegt dann irgendwann mal nur zu zwei hinten, wo du dir denkst, das gibt es doch gar nicht. Jetzt haben die echt eine Chance. Und dann hat Liverpool versucht, das Spiel zu drehen. Ist rangekommen, ein Ausgleich. Und dann hat es aber zu lange gedauert, bis sie in Führung gegangen sind. Das glaube ich war dann erst in der 84. der Fall. Und dann hat City halt schon das Spiel gedreht gehabt. Ich hätte gerne gesehen, ich habe das gestern zu allen Kollegen gesagt, die haben alle einfach nur wortlos genickt. Ich hätte gerne gesehen, dass Liverpool 2 zu 1 in Führung geht, als City noch in Rückstand gelegen hat. Dann hätte ich gerne gesehen, weil dann hätte ich wirklich gerne erlebt, was dann passiert wäre. Ob City die Kopf frei bekommt, ob die nochmal zurückkommen, ob die das packen, ob die das mental nochmal hinkriegen nach diesen Klatschen, die sie hatten mit diesen Situationen, die sie hatten in den letzten Wochen. Mit Real Madrid, mit West Ham United. Dass da vielleicht nochmal so eine Blockade mehr reinkommt. So dachten die sich, wenn die nicht wollen, dann nehmen es einfach wir. So habe ich das Gefühl gehabt.
Was hat denn jetzt dann letztlich den Unterschied gemacht? Also in der Tabelle ist es ein Punkt. Manchester City hat unglaubliche 93 Punkte, Liverpool hat 92 Punkte. Die haben auch unglaubliche Tordifferenzen, 99 und 94 Tore geschossen. City und Liverpool und jeweils nur 26 kassiert. Also das ist ja eine wirklich untypische Dominanz für die Premier League. Aber was hat den Unterschied zwischen diesen beiden Dominatoren gemacht?
Wir reden im Endeffekt nur ein paar Unentschieden. Also Liverpool hat, versuchen wir uns nicht mal zu überlegen, Mitte Januar lagen die 14 Punkte hinter Manchester City. 14 Punkte. Und haben das nochmal aufgeholt, weil City halt ein paar Unentschieden gespielt hat. Gegen Crystal Palace, gegen Liverpool in einmal, gegen West Ham und gegen Southampton. Das waren diese vier Spiele, im Endeffekt gute Niederlage, aber die hatte Liverpool auch mal drinnen. Also es waren wirklich so kleine Unentschieden und Liverpool hat einfach durchmarschiert. 18 Spiele ungeschlagen und deswegen sind die da wieder angekommen. Und dann war halt die Frage, wer hat im Endeffekt mehr oder weniger Punkte gelassen. Und das ist natürlich dann die große Frage gewesen, auch natürlich am letzten Spieltag, ob da nochmal wirklich beide gewinnen können oder nicht. Aber im Endeffekt war City halt einfach am Ende nicht so stabil, Liverpool am Anfang nicht so stabil. Und dann war es halt wirklich am Ende, im Endeffekt nur ein Zeller.
Und Ilkay Gündoğan, der da im letzten Spiel gegen Aston Villa mit verantwortlich war, das zu drehen. Wie waren denn die Reaktionen, so wie du es schon, also so du es denn schon mitbekommen hast, in England auf dieses Saisonfinale?
Na ja, also natürlich, also was man so gesehen hat, ich habe ja auch so, wir hatten einen Reporter vor Ort, der meinte, das war jetzt, die Meisterfeier war jetzt nicht so ausgelassen, wie das jetzt vielleicht bei Liverpool gewesen wäre. Ich glaube, an der Enfield Road wäre da nochmal ein bisschen mehr Feuer gewesen. Da glaube ich, ist die halt einfach in der Kultur noch nicht so megaveit. Vor allem, die haben jetzt auch schon ein paar Titel geholt. Klar, mich freut es für einzelne Spieler, für Jack Grealish zum Beispiel, der ja unbedingt diesen Titel wollte, deswegen dahin gewechselt ist, klar. Das sind dann so Sachen, die dazugehören. Insgesamt war das schon eine große Feier, aber ich glaube, das ist natürlich mit solchen Bildern, wie wir aus Frankfurt gesehen haben nach der Europa League, das ist nicht zu vergleichen. Also das ist nochmal eine ganz andere Liga. Ich glaube, da ist einfach die Fan-Kultur auch eine andere. Letztes Mal hat mich ein Kollege gefragt, der auch in der Premier League arbeitet. Da darf ich nicht genauer ins Detail gehen. Da hat die Frau mich gefragt, was ist der größte Unterschied in der Fan-Kultur? Ich glaube, der Engländer ist analytischer. Der steht auf, wenn der Ball in den Strafraum fliegt, und der versucht dann zu analysieren, wieso hat es nicht geklappt. Dann wird auf der Tribüne diskutiert, der deutsche Fan ist halt eher Leidenschaft singen, dabei sein, abgehen, Choreografien. Das wirkt sich dann natürlich auch auf die Feier aus.
Und wie wird das gesehen, dass eben jetzt zwei Mannschaften so weit vor allen anderen laufen? Chelsea und Toppenhän haben jeweils 74 und 71 Punkte. Das ist ein irrer Abstand von 18 Punkten zwischen Chelsea und Liverpool. Da gibt es eine Lücke, die untypisch ist für die Premier League, oder zumindest lange untypisch war. Vielleicht muss man sagen, mit Guardiola und Klopp haben sich da die Grenzen nach oben hin verschoben. Wird das schon problematisiert in England? Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Ich glaube, dass diese Mannschaften einfach dafür gefeiert werden, was sie momentan machen. Sie sind einfach momentan zwei der besten vier Teams der Welt. Das ist auch genau so richtig. Es gab bis jetzt in der Premier League-Historie zweimal den Fall, dass zwei Teams über 90 Punkte geholt haben. Das war jeweils in den letzten Jahren, eben diese Saison und dann diese Saison, glaube ich, vor zwei Jahren. Auch damals City gegen Liverpool. Diese beiden Mannschaften haben das geschafft. Da wird einfach hervorragende Arbeit geleistet und das wird schon honoriert. Was ich ehrlich gesagt nicht erwartet hätte, ist, dass Chelsea so weiter hinterlegt. Ich hätte gerade nach dem Start gedacht, es würde eher ein Dreikampf werden, in dem Chelsea dann schon ein bisschen abfallen wird. Aber ich dachte, dass nach dem Champions League-Sieg die Entwicklung bei Chelsea weiter voranschreiten würde und das ist ausgeblieben. Sie haben natürlich sehr viele Spiele gemacht. Sie waren ja wirklich lange Zeit dabei. Dann haben sie sehr viele Spiele gehabt, auch mit der Club-WM natürlich, die dich dann rausreißt. Sie hatten viele Verletzte, gerade über die Außenbahnen, was für das Chelsea-Spiel sehr, sehr wichtig ist. Und für deren Drive da vorne, Lukaku hat überhaupt nicht gezündet. Ich habe da mit jemandem aus dem Club mal gesprochen, die dachten schon, dass das fehlende Puzzleteil wäre. Sie haben gesagt, sie haben eigentlich fast die perfekte Balance, haben eine sehr gute Defensive, eine sehr gute Organisation im Mittelfeld. Aber es fehlt vorne der Anker, der auch noch mal Stress macht. Und das konnte er überhaupt nicht sein. Und dann kommt natürlich noch dazu diese Ärger um Abramovic. Also der hat natürlich dann endgültig einen Stecker gezogen. Das muss man schon auch so sagen.
Das ist die Premier League. Wir hatten noch einen Meisterschaftsrennen, das sich erst am letzten Spieltag entschieden hat. Alex weiß schon, dass er sich jetzt entspannen kann, denn es kann sich hier nur um die Serie A handeln. Marius, Milan oder Inter? Es ist am Ende Milan geworden. Beide haben klar und deutlich gewonnen, haben auch schon sehr früh geführt. Hat dann die Spannung deshalb auch schon so ein bisschen gefehlt? Oder wie hast du jetzt dieses Saisonfinale dann am letzten Spieltag erlebt?
Also als wir heute Vormittag die Saison-Rückschau quasi von Serie A am Moor aufgenommen haben, hat Mario Rika gesagt, passenderweise, derjenige oder diejenige, der das Drehbuch für diesen letzten Spieltag geschrieben hat und wie es dann im Endeffekt abgelaufen ist, wird auf jeden Fall keine Krimi-Autorin oder Krimi-Autor mehr. Denn Milan hat von vornherein, die haben ja in Sao Solo gespielt, übrigens, in das Stadion passen so 22.000 rein, davon waren glaube ich 18.000 Karten an Milan Tifosi verkauft. Also das Stadion war komplett rot und schwarz, Heimspielatmosphäre komplett so. Sao Solo ist auch eher so ein Hoffenheim-Vergleich von der Fernseh-Ende vom Verein her. Also da wurde nicht so viel entgegengesetzt und die sind von vornherein so krass draufgegangen, haben so hochgepresst und den Gegner unter Druck gesetzt und zu Fehlern gezwungen, die dann auch nach, ich glaube, nach einer Viertelstunde stand es schon 2 zu Null. Und dann hat man auch, als man mitbekommen hat, dass das in San Siro, wo Inter ja gegen Sampdoria gespielt hat, als das angekommen ist, dass da so ein bisschen die Spannung rausgeht. Also Inter hat das Spiel zwar gewonnen, auch souverän letztlich, aber man hat den Spielern schon angemerkt, die wissen, da passiert jetzt nichts mehr. Wir haben die Meisterschaft verloren. Und Milan hat den Drive, den sie in den letzten Wochen hatten, einfach komplett auch ins letzte Spiel umgesetzt bekommen und sich das dann nicht mehr nehmen lassen. Also das ist jetzt, seit sie die Tabellenführung übernommen haben, so von der Mentalität, die sie gezeigt haben, auf dem Platz her super beeindruckend gewesen. Man muss ja bedenken, dass das eine sehr junge Mannschaft ist, abgesehen von den Zlatans und Girous, da ganz vorne den ganz Alten sind das vor allem auch viele sehr junge Spieler. Und dass die da aber nicht noch ein einziges Mal irgendwie ins Schlingern quasi gekommen sind, das ist aller Ehren wert und da kann ich nur meinen Hut vorziehen und deswegen auch letztlich verdienter Meister. Ich weiß noch, letztes Mal war ich hier, glaube ich, im Rasenfunk Anfang Dezember oder so, da hatte ich Inter gerade im Stadion gesehen und da habe ich noch gesagt, die lassen sich das auf jeden Fall nicht mehr nehmen, haben sie aber.
Haben sie aber tatsächlich und Olivier Giroud wieder mit zwei Toren, das ist irgendwie auch so, ja, also du hast es ja schon gesagt, eigentlich eine sehr junge Mannschaft, aber diese in Anführungszeichen alten Stützen, die braucht es eben einfach und irgendwie habe ich das Gefühl, Giroud ist derjenige, der trifft, wenn es drauf ankommt.
Das stimmt, das kann man so sagen. Er hat das Derby entschieden, das Mayländer Derby im, lass mich lügen, März oder Ende Februar und das war so ein bisschen vielleicht der Knackpunkt danach oder in dieser Phase hatte Inter auch im Zuge des Champions League-Achtelfinals gegen Liverpool, was sehr viel Kraft ihnen gekostet hat. Da haben sie es so ein bisschen verspielt und Milan lag ja auch gegen Inter schon zurück und dann ist Giroud einmal quasi der Ball in den Fuß gefallen und dann stand da nochmal Gold richtig so, wie er eben seine Tore erzielt und das, also ab diesem Zeitpunkt hat man, glaube ich, sie hatten vorher vor dem Spiel sieben Punkte Rückstand, wenn Inter das gewonnen hätte, dann wäre es eigentlich vorbei gewesen und ab dem Moment hat man, glaube ich, bei den Rassoneri so richtig wieder dran geglaubt oder so richtig dran geglaubt und das dann eben komplett bis zum Ende durchgezogen.
Das letzte Mal wurde Milan vor über zehn Jahren, also vor elf Jahren, um genau zu sein, Meister 2010 2011. Was bedeutet das für den AC, diese neue Meisterschaft?
Alles. Also das ist, man hat die Bilder gesehen von der Piazza Duomo, wie viele Leute da gewesen sind, wie viele Leute auch sonst in Städten, wo es starke Milan-Fanbases gibt. Es gibt ja ein Video, das habe ich bei Twitter auch geteilt, aus Tirana, wo mehrere zehntausend Leute auf einem Platz zusammenkommen in Rot und Schwarz und das gefeiert haben. Milan hat ja seit dieser letzten Meisterschaft, was da noch so die Ausläufe dieser ganz großen Generation waren, die die zweimal Champions League-Sieger gewonnen sind, da waren noch. Seedorf und Catuso und Nesta dabei. Was danach so passiert ist mit dem Abgang des vereinstigen Patrons bei Lusconi und danach wurde der Verein zweimal verkauft, war in chinesischer Hand jetzt ja mit Elliot, einem US-amerikanischen Investmentfonds. Und da ist zwischen in diesen elf Jahren, ist so viel eigentlich kaputt gemacht worden, dass es auch höchst beeindruckend ist, wie es seit Elliot, dann Gazides, den kennt Jogina natürlich von Arsenal, der ist ja Vorstandsvorsitzender und Paolo Maldini als Technischer Direktor, seit die da sind, wie dieses Ruder umgerissen wurde und wie innerhalb von zwei, drei Jahren aus diesem Verein wieder ein Meister gemacht wurde. Auch das nötigt mir absolut höchsten Respekt ab.
Das ist die Sicht von Milan. Dazu gehört ja aber auch, dass andere nicht den Scudetto gewinnen konnten. Also einmal Inter als Titelverteidiger, aber auch Napoli und natürlich Juve schon häufiger thematisiert. Die sind dann schon deutlich abgeschlagen. Also Napoli liegt sieben Punkte von der Tabellenspitze entfernt und bei Juventus sind es sogar 16 Punkte am Ende, die das trennen. Juve muss froh sein, dass man die Champions League geschafft hat, werden jetzt auch souverän hinten raus und man hat sich aber dann in Juveart schon wieder mit zwei Niederlagen und einem Unentschieden verabschiedet. Also ganz komische Saison. Wenn wir kurz auf die Konkurrenz blicken, warum hat es keine andere geschafft, Meister zu werden?
Also im Endeffekt war es bei Inter ja eben super knapp und wenn sie am Ende den Titel geholt hätten, dann hätte auch wahrscheinlich niemand gesagt, dass das wäre jetzt irgendwie nicht verdient gewesen und Milan hätte es auf jeden Fall schaffen müssen. Also Inter war eigentlich von vorne weg so ein bisschen den Dominator hatten, aber eben dann in dieser Phase, die ich angesprochen habe, wo sie das Champions League-Achtelfinale gegen Liverpool gespielt haben, wo sie das Derby gegen Milan verloren haben, da haben sie es so ein bisschen aus der Hand gegeben. Und wir haben natürlich auch versucht, das irgendwie zu analysieren und Mario meinte zum Beispiel auch, dass er in den Spielen, die er kommentiert hat, das Gefühl hatte, und das konnte ich jetzt aus meiner Beobachtung auch bestätigen, dass die Mannschaft in dieser Phase teilweise ein bisschen überspielt gewirkt hat. Simone Nsagi, der Trainer, hat sehr viel an seiner ersten Elf festgehalten. Ein Spieler wie Nicolo Barella und Lotharo Martinez, die ja eigentlich absolute Stützen sind, den hat man da angemerkt, dass sie vielleicht mal eine Pause bräuchten in diesem Moment. Die haben sie nicht bekommen. Gerade Barella, der ja eigentlich sonst so eine Art Pferdelunge hat, wirkte da komplett platt, hatte ja auch die EM noch bis zum Finale gespielt mit Italien. Und dann hat mit Brosowitsch, der dieses Metronom quasi zwischen Abwehr und Angriff auch mal gesperrt und verletzt gefehlt und in diesen Spielen hat Inter eben die Punkte abgegeben. Und dann haben sie irgendwann die Form wiedergefunden, gerade nachdem sie das andere Derby, das gegen Juventus gewonnen haben. Robin Großens hat danach gesagt, das war das Spiel, wo danach haben wir gesagt, wir werden auf jeden Fall Meister. Ja, aber hat nicht sollen sein, weil Milan dann eben die Punkte auch nicht mehr abgegeben hat.
Die Starke von Milan haben wir vorhin schon angesprochen. Was ist mit den anderen potenziellen Meisterschaftskandidaten?
Juve hat es ja eigentlich schon am Anfang der Saison verspielt. Man ist ja sehr, sehr schlecht gestattet, historisch schlecht. Ich glaube, nach den ersten zehn Spielen so schlecht war man das letzte Mal vor 60 Jahren. Ist dann irgendwann wieder in Form gekommen, hat auch eine Siegesserie gehabt. Aber um ganz vorne dann ranzukommen, hat es auch nicht mehr gereicht. Wenn sie dieses Spiel gegen Inter gewonnen hätten, dann hätte man denken können, okay, jetzt ist irgendwie wieder das alte Juve wieder da. Dann gewinnt man noch die restlichen sieben Spiele, drücke ich 1 zu 0 und ist am Ende doch Meister. Aber soweit ist die Mannschaft einfach noch nicht wieder. Da ist in der Kaderzusammenstellung einfach über die letzten Jahre zu viel falsch gemacht worden. Da konnte dann auch mit Max Hallegri, der alte Meistertrainer, das nicht wieder rausreißen sozusagen. Bei Napoli hat so ein bisschen die alte Napolikrankheit zugeschlagen, dass man mit dem Druck, womöglich, ich kann das ja auch nur mutmaßen, aber dass das wirkte eben so, dass man mit dem Druck, wir haben vielleicht auch mal den Matchball, weil wir die anderen beiden haben nicht gewonnen. Jetzt haben wir am Sonntagabend, können wir davonziehen oder so. Das hat dann auch immer nicht geklappt. Gerade in den größeren Spielen gegen Milan, gegen die Roma, gegen Florenz hat man da dann Federn gelassen. Nachher kam dann auch von Alex Meret, dem Ersatztorwart gegen Empolinen, ein ganz schlimmer Torwart-Pazzer hinzu, deswegen sie dieses Spiel auch verloren haben. Bei Napoli war das in den letzten Jahren immer schon so eine Nerven-Sache, und das hat sich auch diese Saison wieder zum Ende hin quasi komplett durchgezogen.
Apropos Nerven-Sache, das Nerven-Sache war nicht das Meisterschaftsrennen in der spanischen Liga, hat sich aber schon länger so angedeutet. Also ich weiß nicht, Alex, wie du das jetzt, diese Last-Minute-Finishes hier gerade bewertet hast. Später werde ich mit Alexi ja auch noch über ein Meisterschaftsrennen sprechen, was schon lange entschieden ist. In der Liga ist es real geworden mit 13 Punkten Vorsprung vor Barca und Atletico. Wer einfach nur so auf die Tabelle blicken würde, Real, Barca, Atletico, Sevilla, der würde sagen, ist ja alles wie immer in Spanien. War denn auch alles wie immer? Ja, die Top 4 sind die gleichen wie letztes Jahr und man konnte sie tatsächlich so oder so ähnlich, vielleicht in leicht andere Konstellationen vorab tippen. Es ist also überhaupt keine Überraschung, dass die 4 am Ende auf den ersten vier Rängen gelandet sind. Aber für mich war es ein ticken eine Überraschung, dass es A, überhaupt nicht spannend wurde im Meisterschaftskampf, dass Real Madrid ja wirklich spaziert ist zum Titel und B, sogar ein bisschen spannend, dass Atletico ja seinen Titel nicht nur nicht verteidigen konnte, sondern auch dermaßen viel Abstand, nämlich sage und schreibe 15 Punkte, auf Real Madrid hat. Wir erinnern uns, letztes Jahr hat Atletico ja den Meistertitel gewonnen, aber in dieser Saison konnten sie überhaupt nicht mithalten mit Real Madrid. Und deswegen war es schon ein bisschen überraschend und auch enttäuschend aus Atleticos Sicht, aber ja, aus Real Madrid Sicht wirklich ein Spaziergang zum Titel und für La Liga natürlich sehr, sehr schade. Und auch für mich hier als Repräsentant La Liga, ich kann nicht mithalten mit den anderen spannenden Meisterschaftskämpfen. Ja, ich fürchte, das hatte ich auch nicht überrascht, dass du als Letzter erst vom 38. Spieltag berichten darfst. Aber Ehre wem Ehre gebührt, lass ein paar Worte zu Real Madrid verlieren. In deren Saison ist ja genauso wie die des FC Liverpool noch nicht vorbei. Es wurde auch noch im Champions League-Finale ein Aufeinandertreffen geben. Und es gab viele Themen, die jetzt auch an diesem Wochenende vielleicht noch mit dazugekommen sind. Aber bevor wir dazu kommen, was hat denn Real Madrid in dieser Saison stark gemacht und dann letztlich auch diesen Titel ermöglicht? Wir haben ja unter anderem im direkten Kontrast mit Barca gesehen. Das ist nicht so selbstverständlich alles. Ja, ich würde tatsächlich sagen, mit vier Wörtern kann man es zusammenfassen, warum Real Madrid Meister ist. Sie waren konstanter, souveräner, abgeklärter und ruhiger. Also sie überragen selten, aber sie sind einfach sehr, sehr souverän, sehr konstant. Und auch wenn das Spiel nicht so für sie läuft, sie finden immer irgendwie Mittel und Wege, das Spiel dann zu gewinnen. Sie sind nicht immer bei 100 Prozent oder 110 Prozent, sondern sie wissen, auch mit 80 Prozent können wir Spiele in der Liga oftmals gewinnen, teilweise sogar in der Champions League, wie wir gesehen haben. Also sie sind einfach wirklich, sie ruhen in sich selbst, sie glauben an ihre Stärke und so haben sie die meisten Siege eingefahren, sie haben die meisten Tore geschossen in der Liga, 80 an der Zahl. Die zweitwenigsten Gegentore mit 31, nur Sevilla hatte ein Tor weniger kassiert. Sie haben zusammen mit Sevilla die wenigsten Niederlagen. Also es war von vorne bis hinten souverän. Ab dem dritten Spieltag war Real Madrid durchgängig auf Platz 1 gestanden. Ich glaube, das allein spricht Bände. Allerdings, und mit dem Meistertrainer Carlo Ancelotti, wo man als Beobachter, der die Bundesliga verfolgt, scheint es zwei Ancelottis zu geben. Es gibt den internationalen Ancelotti, der ist genau so, wie man es jetzt auch erlebt hat, ruhig. Die Augenbraue, sie hebt sich mal einen Millimeter mehr als sonst, aber ansonsten verändert sich da eigentlich nichts. Und erscheint vor allem seine Mannschaft, die dominiert jetzt selten taktisch, sondern so, wie du es gesprochen hast, eher aus so einer Selbstgewissheit heraus. Und so kann man sogar dramatische Spiele auf dem Platz hinbekommen. Bricht sich irgendwie mit dem Bild von Ancelotti als Bayern-Trainer, aber sieht man vielleicht, was für ein Verein Bayern ist, ehrlicherweise. Wie würdest du denn seinen Anteil an diesem Titel bemessen? Es heißt ja immer so schön, eine Mannschaft ist ein Spiegelbild des Trainers und spielt so wie der Trainer. Und da sind wir wieder beim Thema konstant souverän, abgeklärt, ruhig. Dafür steht ja Ancelotti irgendwie und so. Transportiert er das auf seine Mannschaft oder projiziert das auf seine Mannschaft und so spielt sie auch immer wieder. Also wirklich dieses abgeklärte, ruhige, man glaubt an sich selbst, auch wenn es mal nicht läuft und es steht in der 75. Null Null oder man liegt sogar hinten. Real Madrid glaubt an sich. Das ist irgendwo sicherlich auch dem Trainer zuzuschreiben, weil er einfach mehr Erfahrung hat als jeder andere Trainer in dieser Liga. Kurioser, kuriose Statistik. Ancelotti hat ja in dieser Saison einen Rekord aufgestellt, der erste Trainer, der in allen fünf großen Ligen meistert geworden ist. Also in Deutschland, in Italien, in Frankreich, in England und jetzt in Spanien. Aber kurioserweise immer nur jeweils ein einziges Mal in, ich glaube, 20 plus Jahren als Trainer. Sofort entlassen. Ja, also ein toller Rekord, aber trotzdem, er schafft sehr, sehr selten, Meister zu werden. Du hast es ja gesagt, er ist eher für Europa bekannt, dass er da seine Mannschaft in der Regel zum Champions-League-Titel führt. Wir werden sehen, ob es erneut dazu kommt am Samstag. Aber ja, auch deswegen die von mir eingangs der Satz, dass es ein bisschen überraschend war, dass Real Madrid Meister geworden ist, vor allem so souverän und locker Meister geworden ist. Denn Ancelotti war ja nicht unbedingt die allererste Wahl oder die logischste Wahl nach einer sehr unterdurchschnittlichen Saison beim FC Everton hat, so heißt es in Spanien, Real Madrid oder Florentino Perez, der Präsident schlicht und ergreifend keinen besseren gefunden. Und dann dachte er sich, na dann hole ich meinen alten Kollegen und Kumpel Carlo zurück. Ja, und dass er dann Meister wird. Ich glaube, ich persönlich hätte damit so nicht gerechnet, weil er ein bisschen eine Verlegenheitslösung war, Ancelotti. Carlo regelt. Du, deutsche Männer- und Nationalmannschaft ist so mal ins WM-Finale gekommen, 2002. Rudi Völler auch. Eigentlich nur der Platzhalter für Christoph Daum. Also das kann alles funktionieren. Habe ich gerade Rudi Völler mit Carlo Ancelotti verglichen? Die Saison war auch für mich lang. Lass darüber hinweggehen. Es ist noch etwas passiert an diesem Wochenende, was dann eben auch für Real wichtig war. Wir werden es auch im Ligue 1-Teil mit Alexis noch besprechen. Kylian Mbappé hat bekannt gegeben, dass er nicht zu Real wächst, sondern bei PSG bleibt. Und das hat für Wut und Zorn gesorgt. Der Chef von La Liga droht jetzt sogar PSG, sieht den Abgesang des Fußballs. Wie bewertest du denn das, was da am Wochenende passiert ist, aus Sicht von Real? Ich glaube, für Real Madrid ist das wirklich ein richtiger Schlag. Emotional natürlich, man fühlt sich in der Ehre im Stolz gekränkt, aber auch sportlich natürlich ein enormer Schlag. Ich glaube, wir sind uns alle einig, dass Kylian Mbappé einer der drei besten Fußballer auf dem Planeten aktuell ist. Vielleicht der allerbeste, wenn er noch nicht ist, dann wird er erst wohl in den nächsten paar Jahren. So einen Spieler nicht zu bekommen, obwohl du vermeintlich schon die Zusage hattest, seit Wochen, seit Monaten, seit vielleicht einem Jahr ist sportlich ein absoluter Tiefschlag für den Madridismo, vor allem aber für Florentino Perez. Der Fest damit gerechnet hat, der Fest Kylian Mbappé zur weltweiten Nummer 1 machen wollte, zu dem Schlüsselspieler, zu dem Puzzlestück des neuen Real Madrids, das ja dann ins neue umgebaute Bernabeu umzieht, also eine neue Ära des Madridismo steht an. Und Kylian Mbappé war der auserwählte Superstar, der Real Madrid in diese neue Ära führen sollte. Also weit mehr als nur ein sehr, sehr, sehr guter Fußballer, den man sich eben holt, weil er auf dem Markt ist. Er war ja ablösefrei. Also wirklich ein absolutes Puzzlestück. Und den dann nicht zu bekommen, obwohl man sich hinter den Kulissen längst einig war, so heißt es in Madrid, ist wirklich ein enormer Tiefschlag. Die Presse-Stimmen in Spanien haben sich überschlagen. Also da war wirklich die Ehre des Madridismus, war gekränkt und ist noch immer gekränkt. Das ist schon mächtig abgegangen da in den Gazetten Spaniens. Also das stimmt alles, was du sagst. Ich habe gerade überlegt, ob wir den Begriff ablösefrei überhaupt noch verwenden sollten. Gut, keine Transfer-Ablöse. Wahrscheinlich müsste man so, aber natürlich fließend Gelder. Man muss nicht an PhD zahlen, sondern an der Mbappé. Aber das ist ja hunderte Millionen. Richtig, das ist schon irre. Habt ihr anderen beiden dazu eine Meinung? Jogi, Marius, zu diesem Wechsel?
Ich würde gerne eine Frage stellen, wenn ich ehrlich bin. Weil es gab ja sofort diese Diskussion, dass doch der Präsident von La Liga gesagt hat, das ist doch eine Sauerei, PSG kann sich das gar nicht leisten mit diesem Finanzergebnis, das die hatten. Jetzt wissen wir aber zum Beispiel von Barcelona, dass die sich am Ferran Torres nicht mal richtig leisten konnten und dass da schon wie geschoben worden ist. Hätte sich denn Real Madrid, die ja auch einen riesengroßen aufgeblähten Kader haben oder einen teuren Kader, hätten die sich das einfach so leisten können? Weil ich meine, die Frage muss man dann ihrem Umkehrschutz auch stellen.
Real Madrid spart tatsächlich seit vielen, vielen Jahren auf Mbappé. Nicht nur bezüglich Ablöse, da wären natürlich jetzt keine geflossen, aber letztes Jahr haben sie angeblich 180 Millionen Ablöse geboten für einen Spieler, der ein Jahr vor Vertragsende stand. Auch schon völlig verrückt. Aber sie haben eben auch wirklich gespart. Also man muss sich das so vorstellen, immer wieder Geld eingenommen und das in so eine kleine französische Sparbüchse rein. Sie haben beispielsweise Ödegard verkauft, da weißt ja du, Jogi, Bescheid, zu Arsenal. Ist ja jetzt auch nicht der blindeste Spieler, kann auch einiges, aber sie haben wirklich immer wieder fast schon wie in der NBA, in der Basketball-Liga Assets veräußert, um eben Geld zu sparen, Geld einzunehmen, weil sie alles in die Sparbüchse im Mbappé reingesteckt haben, um ihn finanzieren zu können. Wie gesagt, jetzt nicht zwingend in dem Sommer an Ablöse, aber eben an Bonuszahlungen, an Zahlungen an den Agenten oder an die Familie oder eben an sein exorbitantes Gehalt. Sie hätten ihn sich leisten können, sie haben darauf gespart, aber PSG hat halt Mittel und Gelder zur Verfügung, die alles andere sprengen. Da sind wir, glaube ich, schon schnell beim Thema Wettbewerbsverzeihung, was PSG da macht.
Wenn ich da noch einmal kurz einhaken darf, das muss man ja auch bedenken, dass bei Real ein paar Verträge auslaufen, unter anderem vom bestbezahlten Hobbygolfer der Welt. Und da wird dann ja auch ein bisschen was vom Budget wieder frei. Vielleicht mit dem jetzt schnell verlängern, wenn MWP nicht kommt.
Zu erhöhten Bezügen. Ja, Wettbewerbsverzeihung, Wettbewerbsverzeihung natürlich in alle Richtungen. Also es ist klar, dass Akteure, denen Geld völlig egal ist, und damit meine ich Qatar und Abu Dhabi, dass die den Wettbewerb verzahren, aus Sicht von Real Betis. Aber zum Beispiel, da sind dann vielleicht die Mitleidstraining jetzt auch nicht ganz so riesig, wenn man sich anguckt, dass Real national dominiert hat. Du hast es ja gesagt, nicht mal mit einem sportlich überlegenen Ansatz, sondern einfach nur aufgrund der eigenen Qualität diesen Meistertitel sehr souverän eingefahren hat, ohne dass es spannend wurde. Also wie immer gibt es da zwei Sichten drauf. Jetzt haben wir Barca auf zwei, Atletico auf drei. Bei Barca haben wir viel gesprochen, bei denen hängst du natürlich auch mit am nächsten dran. Da sah es zwischendurch richtig dramatisch aus. Stichwort Lyc de Jong, ohne dass ich jetzt den Spieler damit meine, aber er ist ein Symbol dafür, was bei Barca an Qualität zwischenzeitlich verloren ging, wo man dann aber wieder nachjustieren konnte. Haben wir hier ja auch schon mal besprochen. Ist denn jetzt mit diesem zweiten Tabellenplatz, der auch ungefährdet war am Ende, also man konnte sich jetzt noch einen Unentschieden und eine Niederlage leisten und wurde trotzdem von Atletico nicht bedrängt von hinten. Ist die Welt jetzt wieder halbwegs in Ordnung? Na ja, auch da gibt es zwei Sichtweisen. Also es war, dass irgendwo das Minimalziel, also Minimalziel grundsätzlich Champions League für Barca aufgrund der finanziellen Schwierigkeiten war sehr, sehr wichtig, zweiter zu werden, weil sie dadurch nächstes Jahr im Supercup mitspielen, der in Saudi-Arabien ausgetragen wird. Das ist dann wieder das andere Thema. Nur da gibt es eben schön viel Geld. Also ich glaube, für die Teilnahme alleine am Supercup ist ja ein Final Four in Spanien. Da spielt also der Meister mit, der Zweitplatzierte, der Pokalsieger und der Pokalfinalist. Und Barca und Real Madrid haben eine kleine Sonderstellung und bekommen eine Antrittsgage allein von roundabout 8 Millionen Euro. Das ist schon mal gar nicht so schlecht für nur ein Halbfinale. Und wenn sie dann natürlich ins Finale einziehen oder das Ding sogar gewinnen, gibt es noch ein paar Millionen hin oben drauf. Also allein aus finanzieller Sicht war es für Barca sehr, sehr wichtig, zweiter zu werden, nicht nur natürlich die Champions League zu erreichen, weil es da ja viele garantierte Millionen gibt, sondern eben auch die Supercopa-Millionen mitzunehmen. Aber das war wirklich das absolut größte oder mindeste Ziel, das Minimalziel schlechthin. Alles andere wäre eine absolut desaströse Saison gewesen. Sie war so schon verheerend, schlecht, enttäuschend. Kannst du adjektiv deiner Wahl wählen. Aber immerhin wurde das Schlimmste verhindert. Dazu hat es auch Xavi auf den PKs immer wieder gesagt. Es hätte wesentlich schlimmer laufen können. Sie waren ja zwischenzeitlich neunter im November. November kam Xavi an die Macht, hätte ich jetzt fast gesagt. Wobei es stimmt, er ist ja auch so ein bisschen allmächtig mittlerweile im Verein. Da sah es dann nachher aus, als würden sie die Champions League verpassen. Immerhin haben sie das jetzt geschafft und dann eben auch zweiter geworden. So ist eine sehr schlimme Saison halbwegs okay geendet. Aber gut war es natürlich auch nicht. Und wer noch mal nachvollziehen will, wie das eigentlich gelaufen ist mit Super Cup in Saudi Arabien und wer da noch Antrittsgagen bekommen hat, einfach nur dafür, dass er vermittelt hat, nämlich Piquet-Mitnahmen, der kann das mal kurz in die Suchmaschine seiner Wahl reinwerfen. Auch da nette Nebengeschichten, oder was in dem Fall nicht so nette Nebengeschichten. Natürlich hat sich da jemand persönlich bereichert, aber auch nicht untypisch fürs Fußballgeschäft. So ist es eben dann irgendwie. Und wie ist der Ausblick von Barca? Ich erlaube dir hiermit, den Namen Lewandowski in den Mund zu nehmen. Da gab es eine kleine Vorgeschichte dazu. Ist das jetzt das wichtigste Thema? Ist das jetzt natürlich nicht komplett vergleichbar mit MBP, aber von der sportlichen Bedeutung für Barca, wäre das ähnlich wichtig? Weil man hat doch jetzt eigentlich Obermeister Young. Also was Barca wirklich sehr gut macht, oder was Xavi meiner Meinung nach sehr gut macht, er ist sehr, sehr selbstkritisch und sehr, sehr ehrlich. Auf all seinen Pressekonferenzen verfolgt er logischerweise berufsbedingt jede. Ist er da wirklich, wirklich selbstkritisch, legt den Finger in die Wunde und analysiert immer wieder die Situation und vor allem die Kadersituation und sagt eben, wir brauchen dringend Verstärkung, wir müssen uns dringend verbessern. Also die Mannschaft muss natürlich besser Fußball spielen, muss mental härter werden auf gut Deutsch, muss mehr an sich glauben, braucht mehr Selbstvertrauen, aber vor allem benötigt die Mannschaft auf allen Positionen zwei Spieler. Und das gibt es so aktuell nicht. Beispielsweise links Verteidiger, da spielt Jordi Alba durch, da ist 32. Beispiel auf der 6, Sergio Busquets, ein Urgestein ist 33, 34. Er spielt fast jedes Spiel, hat die meistens 1 als Minuten aller Spieler. Es gibt da einfach keine Konkurrenz, keinen Ersatz. Und im Sturm hat man eben festgestellt, ja Aubameyang kam jetzt dazu, aber mehr als absoluter Notnagel im Winter, hat ein paar sehr, sehr wichtige und auch sehr schöne Tore geschossen, war jetzt aber nicht unbedingt der Wunschstürmer Nr. 1. Und es gibt auch immer wieder Spiele, wie beispielsweise gestern gegen Villarreal, wo er absolut unsichtbar ist, wo er wirklich keine 10 Ballberührungen im Spiel hat. Und ich glaube, da sind wir uns schon einig, dass ein gewisser Robert Lewandowski ein kleiner Upgrade wäre. Also Barca hat erkannt, Xavi hat erkannt, es benötigt unbedingt Verstärkung auf vielen verschiedenen Positionen und eine ist eben der Mittelsturm. Und da wollte man eigentlich Erling Haaland haben. Da sind wir wieder beim Thema Wettbewerbsverzerrung, Gelder, die andere Vereine so nicht haben. Man City hat sich ihn leisten können, Barca eben nicht. Und deswegen ist man jetzt bei Robert Lewandowski gelandet, denn der möchte im Gegensatz zu Erling Haaland unbedingt zum FC Barcelona wechseln, möchte unbedingt den FC Bayern München verlassen. Also Barca sieht da eine Chance, Lewandowski zu bekommen. Ob es klappt? Tja, das wird uns die nächsten Wochen und Monate noch beschäftigen. Ich glaube auch, dass wir das so am Rande mitbekommen werden. Deswegen reicht mir das an der Stelle hier. Aber danke, dass du es noch mal eingeordnet hast. Gerade die Kadertiefe auf den verschiedenen Positionen fand ich interessant. Was ist denn dann zu Atletico zu sagen? Und müssen wir Sevilla in die Mannschaften doch mit aufnehmen, die Meister hätten werden können? Also zwischenzeitlich sah es natürlich so aus, wir hatten auch mal vom Tabellenführer Sevilla gesprochen, wenn ich mich jetzt nicht komplett falsch erinnere. Was ist zu den beiden noch zu sagen? Ja, zwischenzeitlich war Sevilla tatsächlich mehr oder minder einzige Herausforderer von Real Madrid. So im, ich glaube, Dezember, Januar rum, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, Februar vielleicht auch noch. Aber du hast immer gewusst, das werden die nicht durchhalten. Das wird so nicht weitergehen. Und in den letzten Wochen ging fast gar nichts mehr für Sevilla. Sie haben von 15 Spielen irgendwie in der Schlussphase nur so vier oder fünf überhaupt gewinnen können. Also der Sprit war komplett weg, die Luft war aus und so sind sie da gelandet, wo sie naturgemäß in der Reihe hingehören, nämlich gerade mal vierter geworden. Also sie konnten nicht mehr mithalten mit Real Madrid. Und wenn man ehrlich ist, waren sie in der Rückrunde auch ziemlich enttäuscht. In der Hinrunde waren sie nur zwei Punkte hinter Real Madrid, also zweitbestes Hinrundenteam. Rückrunde Sevilla Platz 7. Das zeigt schon auf, sie konnten es einfach nicht durchhalten. Für Spanien natürlich sehr schade, dass es da gar keine Mannschaft gab, die überhaupt irgendwie mithalten konnte mit Real Madrid. Und für Atletico gilt Ähnliches, wobei die mich persönlich die ganze Saison über mehr oder minder enttäuscht haben. Aber Atletico hat ja auch so zwei Gesichter gezeigt in dieser Saison. International konnte man da durchaus noch mal so das alte, bissige Atletico sehen, das auch Erfolg hat mit seinem Fußball. Wir haben das zwar schon mehrfach angesprochen, aber jetzt auch in der Rückschau mit Blick auf die ganze Saison, war das Hauptthema das, dass man in den entscheidenden Situationen das Tor nicht getroffen hat oder dass man... Man hatte auch manchmal diese Wackler mit drin, die so ganz Atletico untypisch waren, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere. Wo würdest du es jetzt dann in der Rückschau einordnen? Wir sprechen ja hier über eine Mannschaft, die eigentlich viel, viel näher an Real hätte dran sein wollen. Ja, Atletico ist tatsächlich irgendwie ein curious case sozusagen. Wirklich Sinn hat das nicht gemacht, was sie in der Saison gezeigt haben. Denn die letztjährige Abwehrstabilität, für die sie ja auch bekannt sind unter Gio Lo Simeone, ging in komplett ab. Letztes Jahr als sie Meister wurden, 25 Gegentore in 38 Spielen. Das ist typisch Atletico, so kennt ihr sie alle. In dieser Saison gab es satte 43 Gegentore nur in La Liga. Wenn man sich die Ergebnisse mal durchschaut, gab es immer wieder Spieler, die 3 zu 2, 3 zu 3, 3 zu 4 ausgingen. Also absolut atypisch, untypisch und auch irgendwo unerklärlich, dass in jegliche defensive Stabilität abgegangen ist. Jan Oblak beispielsweise. Letztes Jahr eine grandiose Saison gespielt und der große Rückstand Rückhalt gewesen hat. Immer wieder Patzer gehabt. Ich glaube, allein 3 oder 4 oder 5 Patzer, die man von keinem Torhüter überhaupt auf Profieniveau so kennt. Deswegen hat Atletico da irgendwie nie in seinen Rhythmus gefunden, in seinen altbekannten Rhythmus, dass man eben stabil steht und dann eben das eine Tor mehr schießt als der Gegner, also irgendwie 1-0-2-0 gewinnen. Das gab es sehr, sehr selten. Sie waren da sehr launisch. Und die Champions League war so die große Ausnahme. Denn das, was Atletico gegen Man City gezeigt hat, war eben das typische Atletico. 0-0 im Hinspiel, 0-1 im Hinspiel mit keinem Torschuss. Und im Rückspiel 0-0. Aber da hätten sie City beinahe geschlagen und beinahe niedergerungen. Aber das war irgendwie eine Anomalie in der Saison. Also dieses Atletico in der Champions League gegen Man City hat man so in La Liga sehr, sehr selten nur gesehen. Gut, also das war das Meisterschaftsrennen in diesen drei Ligen. Jetzt wird es ein bisschen kürzer, die Einzesegmente. Ich habe verschiedene weitere Fragen an euch. Und die gebe ich jetzt einfach rei umdurch. Marius, du darfst mal anfangen. Wer waren denn für dich, abgesehen von den Dingen, die wir jetzt eben schon angesprochen haben, die Überraschungen in dieser Saison?
Also auf jeden Fall positiv. Fangen wir mit positiv an. Muss man natürlich erst mal trotzdem Mila nennen, aber darüber haben wir ja schon gesprochen. Was mich auf jeden Fall auch sehr positiv überrascht hat, ist die Entwicklung der Fiorentiner, die erstmals seit langem wieder den Europa Cup erreicht haben. Durch ein Sieg gegen Juve am Samstag, am letzten Spieltag, haben sie die Conference League erreicht. Da kann man natürlich sagen, okay, es ist nur in Anführungszeichen die Conference League, aber ich glaube, dass die Tifosi aus Florenz da richtig Bock drauf haben nächstes Jahr und dass da das Stadion auch entsprechend voll wird und euphorisch begleitet wird, dass man eben endlich mal wieder dabei ist, nachdem man in den letzten Jahren meistens nicht direkt gegen den Abstieg gespielt hat, aber dann doch eher so im Niemandsland der Tabelle rumgeguckt ist und das natürlich den Ansprüchen dieses Traditionsvereins nicht genügt. Was auf jeden Fall zu dem erwähnenswert ist, sind die Entwicklungen von Hellas Verona und dem FC Turin. Turino hatte ja vor der Saison von Hellas den Trainer abgeworben, Ivan Juric, und ist jetzt auf einem guten zehnten Platz gelandet am Ende. Da werden jetzt ein paar der Topspieler Bremer, der Verteidiger, Pellotti im Sturm, Pobegal im Mittelfeld, Spieler, den Verein wahrscheinlich verlassen. Aber das ist so ein Verein, die haben zwar Probleme damit, wenn sie gegen Vereine spielen, wo sie selbst auch mal ein bisschen das Offensivspiel gestalten müssen, aber die so wahrscheinlich die ekligste Mannschaft in ganz Italien sind, wenn es gegen die Top-Vereine geht. Und Hellas, da hat Igor Tudor übernommen, der früher bei Juve gespielt hat unter anderem. Und der hat zwar nicht unter Juric quasi gelernt als Trainer, aber er setzt diese Arbeit so ein bisschen, die er bei Hellas geleistet hat. Und da war das System auch so ähnlich, wie es jetzt in Turin ist. Der setzt das so ein bisschen fort. Und die sind auch einfach unglaublich eklig zu bespielen, machen zeitgleich aber dann auch in der Offensive noch ein bisschen mehr Spaß. Also da ist so ein bisschen Rock'n'Roll-Faktor irgendwie mit drin. Und also das sind so vielleicht von den Mannschaften, die die drei positivsten Überraschungen, jetzt neben Milan natürlich, und negativ natürlich Juve auf der einen Seite, dann leider leider aber auch Atalanta, die ja uns in den letzten Jahren immer enorm begeistert haben. Und diese Saison zum ersten Mal seit drei, vier Jahren den Europa Cup wieder verpasst haben, sind jetzt achter geworden nur am Ende, hatten viele Verletzungsprobleme. Und dann gab es auch einen Streit im Hintergrund quasi mit dem Sportdirektor Sartori und dem Trainer Gasperini, weswegen der Sportdirektor der Gasperini ursprünglich mal zum Verein geholt hatte, jetzt auch am Saisonende geht. Und ich glaube, so diese gesamten, diese Gesamtgemengelage aus Verletzungsproblemen und Streitigkeiten im Hintergrund hat so ein bisschen dafür gesorgt, dass man eben nicht so designen sein, dieses extreme Spiel, was Atalanta ja in den letzten Jahren gezeigt hat, auch immer sehr, sehr offensiv. Und das hat irgendwie nicht mehr so, alles nicht mehr so gut gepasst. Und ja, das ist ein bisschen schade. Ich hatte eigentlich am Anfang gesagt, ich habe sie tatsächlich auf Platz 2 getippt vorhin. Nein, das war im Endeffekt dann ganz, ganz weit daneben. Aber ja, ich hoffe, dass man sich da wieder ein bisschen sammeln kann im nächsten Saison dann auch ohne diese Doppelbelastung oder Dreifachbelastung dann auch wieder angreifen kann.
Welche Überraschungen hat die Premier League für uns bereitgehalten in dieser Saison?
Da muss ich sagen, ich habe natürlich ein spannendes Meisterschaftsfinale gehabt, aber oder wir. Aber was die Überraschungen betrifft, glaube ich, gibt es ehrlich gesagt nicht so mega viele. Das ist so ein bisschen, glaube ich, das Enttäuschende in der Liga, dass es die nicht gibt, dass da viel festgefahren ist, weil Manchester United zum Beispiel wird mit Sicherheit nicht überzeugt, werden wir ja noch darauf kommen in der nächsten Spalte, aber trotzdem haben sie in die Top 6 geschafft. Also die Big Six sind die Top 6 und dann kann man dahinter dann seine Fragen stellen. Also West Ham war schon auf Gang 7 letzte Saison, also haben eigentlich bestätigt, das ist eine Überraschung, es ist jetzt nicht unbedingt, Brighton war lange ein bisschen besser unterwegs, die würde ich vielleicht zu nehmen. Dort hat Graham Potter wirklich herausragende Arbeit geleistet und wirklich aus einem kleinen Verein, einem guten Verein gemacht, mit auch Entwicklungspotenzial und auch gerade, wenn man da aus dem Hintergrund mit Leuten spricht, was die machen. Also wirklich zum Beispiel Moises Caicedo, der jetzt Stamm spielt, den wollte Manchester United, die konnten sich aber nicht gleich einigen und daraufhin ist Brighton einfach hingegangen, hat das Geld auf den Tisch gelegt und sagt, dann holen wir den halt. Dasselbe zum Beispiel Jakob Moda, ich weiß, da war ein deutscher Verein, der hat den auf dem Tisch gehabt, ein Verein, den der Max auch gut kennt und der wurde vorgestellt dort und hat gesagt, das wäre doch ein guter Spieler für euch, so und so und dann hat er gesagt, ja, müssen wir mal abwarten, zwei Wochen später hat er Brighton unterschrieben. Und das sind genau diese Dinge, die die machen, die scouten die Spieler, die bei den Großen vielleicht noch nicht ganz genug oder hoch genug angesehen werden, nehmen die und schauen dann und sagen, okay, wir können die entwickeln, wir machen daraus einen 10-Millionen-Spieler, einen 30-Millionen-Spieler und versuchen uns lang, aber langsam aber stetig nach oben zu hangeln. Deswegen, das ist mit Sicherheit ein Club. Dann Newcastle, okay, also, ich glaube, da brauchen wir jetzt nicht so recht viel drüber reden, das ist mit Sicherheit dann auch noch was. Aber, ja, die haben natürlich jetzt einfach im Endeffekt sich nochmal gerettet und sind auf Hang 11 gesprungen. Respekt dafür, wenn wir später noch dazu kommen. Wenn ich ein Team rausnehmen würde, würde ich einfach nochmal Brent Ford sagen, als Aufsteiger eigentlich nie wirklich Angst gehabt zu haben, abzusteigen. Und sofort dort oben, also quasi wirklich, was alle immer sagen. Ich habe mit Daniel Fakir letztens auch darüber gesprochen, da warst du ja auch dabei, Max, der auch gesagt hat, es ist natürlich immer leicht zu sagen, ich habe in Liga 2 dominiert, dann kommst du in die Premier League und jeder ist eigentlich auf deinem Niveau, wenn nicht sogar drüber. Das heißt, es ist sehr, sehr schwierig, dieses Level, das die anderen natürlich haben, allein schon an Finanzkraft, an Spielerstärke und so weiter, zu matchen und vielleicht sogar noch irgendwie den Weg zu finden, in der Liga standhalten zu können. Und das hat Brentford perfektioniert. Die haben ihren eigenen Fußball gespielt, sehr viel auf Chaos, sehr viel auf zweite Bälle, sehr viel auf Disruption beim Gegner und das hat alles wunderbar funktioniert. Die haben ganz eigen gespielt, es war immer irgendwie anders, athletisch klebrig, aber es hat funktioniert. Und dafür muss man sagen, Thomas Frank, Hut ab.
Athletisch klebrig, das werde ich mir auf jeden Fall merken. Das finde ich, ist eine sehr schöne Formulierung. Ja, Alex, welche Überraschungen gab es denn in La Liga? War es da ähnlich enttäuschend im Gesamten wie in der Premier League? Also, dass man sagt, die ganz großen Überraschungen sind ausgeblieben. Ja, absolut. Ich überlege gerade, wer athletisch klebrig in La Liga sein könnte. Fällt mir jetzt auf die Schnelle gar nicht ein. Nee, von der Tabellenkonstellation her konnte man, ich klammer auf Leiderklammern zu, die Top 7 genauso vorhersagen, wenn auch nicht vielleicht Platz für Platz, aber zumindest welche Mannschaften in den Top 7 landen. Da gab es leider überhaupt keine Überraschungen. Zwischenzeitlich bahnte sich eine Monster-Überraschung an, aber die hielt eben auch nur bis Ende Dezember, Anfang Januar. Rayo Vallecano, der Aufsteiger, war an Weihnachten auf Rang 4 und beendete die Hinrunde auf Platz 6, gewann dann aber bis in den April kein Spiel mehr. Und dementsprechend ist man komplett abgerutscht. Also so wirklich ein spanisches SC Freiburg, ein spanisches Union Berlin sucht man leider vergeblich in La Liga. Die Top 7 sind festgefahren und dahinter sind auch immer die üblichen Verdächtigen. Also ne, so eine wirkliche positive Überraschung mit Black-Off, die Tabelle gab es nicht. Man müsste schon auf die Pokalwettbewerbe gucken, inklusive Champions League. Denn da war natürlich der FC Villarreal die Riesenüberraschung, wenn es hier natürlich nur um La Liga oder hauptsächlich um La Liga gehen könnte, was Villarreal in der Champions League geleistet hat, war grandios, hätte ihnen, glaube ich, kaum jemand zugetraut. Das ist die eine Überraschung mit Blick auf den einen KO-Wettbewerb, mit Blick auf die Copa del Rey. Den anderen KO-Wettbewerb ist natürlich der Pokalsieg von Betis, glaube ich, schon eine Überraschung. Wobei man sagen kann, na ja, wenn Barcelona, Real Madrid und Atletico jeweils früh ausscheiden, dann ist natürlich der Weg frei für die andere Mannschaft. Ja gut, aber das haben wir ja in der Bundesliga unter anderem auch. Und ich habe tatsächlich überlegt, ob zumindest fürs Champions League Real Atlétisch-Klebrig nicht sogar passen könnte. Ja, stimmt. Kann man anwenden, segne ich ab.
Ja, und atletisch als Adjektiv zu verwenden, ist doch schon Weltklasse bei Atletico.
Das ergibt natürlich auf jeden Fall Sinn. Was haben wir denn für Enttäuschungen, Alex, wenn wir jetzt gerade schon in La Liga bleiben? Gab es Mannschaften, die komplett hinter ihren Erwartungen zurückgeblieben sind, außer natürlich, wir haben jetzt Atletico, Barca haben wir schon ein bisschen eingeordnet? Ja, also für mich persönlich, die Enttäuschung der Saison ist Atletico als amtierender Meister. Gerade so dritter werden, also wirklich sich über die Ziellinie robben. Und die Ziellinie ist in dem Fall die Champions League Qualifikation. Sie sind in allen Pokalwettbewerben sehr, sehr früh ausgeschieden. Ja, in der Champions League an Wenzitige scheitelt, das ist natürlich keine Schande und es war spannend. Aber ja, trotzdem recht früh raus, im Pokal sehr früh ausgeschieden, in der Supercoppa, im Halbfinale an. Ich meine, Athletic Bilbao gescheitert. Also da waren sie schon der Favorit, da hätten sie schon zumindest ins Finale kommen müssen. Also aus Athleticos Sicht war das einfach eine sehr, sehr enttäuschende Saison, wie ich fand. Erst recht, weil sie amtierender Meister waren. Erst recht, weil bei Barcelona, man kennt ja die gesamten Turbulenzen, Messi weg, Trainerwechsel, etc. Real Madrid kam ja nur in Anführungszeichen, Ancelotti waren jetzt auch nicht so der Überflieger. Also dass du da nicht annähernd mithalten kannst als amtierender Meister. Und dann, wie gesagt, wie viel waren es? 17 Punkte Rückstand. Auf Real hast du deswegen für mich, Athletico, die Enttäuschung an sich, auch wenn sie natürlich irgendwo trotzdem in ihrem natürlichen Habitat gelandet sind, nämlich 3. und Levantes Abstieg natürlich, wenn man ein bisschen weiter runterguckt, ist dann schon eine Enttäuschung. Denn das ist eine Mannschaft, die sich seit Jahren zwischen Rang 9 und Rang 13 etabliert hat. Und dass die dann komplett runtergepurzelt sind, ist natürlich schon enorm enttäuschend. Vor allem, wenn man bedenkt, wie lange sie auf ihren ersten Sieg warten mussten. Den gab es erst am 20. Spieltag. Und sie haben liegas... sorry, saisonübergreifend einen neuen Negativrekord in Spanien aufgestellt mit 27 Spielen ohne Sieg. Also die letzten sieben Saisonen und die ersten 20 der neuen Saisonen nicht gewonnen. Wer so einen Rekord aufstellt, der ist dann natürlich auch irgendwie so ein bisschen zum Abstieg verdammt. Also aus levante Sicht war das natürlich schon eine herbe Enttäuschung, dass sie abgestiegen sind. Aber da müssen die ja hinten raus noch richtig Punkte gesammelt haben, wenn die bei 35 rauskommen. Etwas spät gab es den Aufschwung. Also hinten raus waren sie dann wirklich gut dabei. Ich glaube, in den letzten sechs Spielen vier gewonnen oder von den letzten acht sechs oder irgendwie sowas. Aber ja, ein bisschen zu spät aufgewacht. Es gab auch drei Trainerwechsel zwischendurch bei Levante. Also wirklich, wie man sich so eine Chaos-Saison eben vorstellt, wenn so ein vermeintlicher Mittelklasse-Club, wobei so kann man sie auch nicht nennen. Sie sind ja wirklich so ein recht kleinerer Verein aus Valencia. Von daher, dass sie überhaupt, ich glaube, sechs oder sieben Jahre oder acht am Stück in der Liga sind, war schon ein enormer Erfolg. Dass es nicht ewig so weitergehen konnte, war auch klar, aber dass sie dann so abstürzen und wie gesagt nicht nur irgendwie normal absteigen, sondern wirklich 20 Spieltage lang auf den einen Sieg warten müssen, das war schon enorm bitter und enorm tragisch und so. Nicht vorhersehbar, deswegen ja meine zweite Enttäuschung quasi. Levante, wir haben die Enttäuschung der Serie A vorhin schon gehört, deswegen, Jogi, darfst du noch deine Enttäuschung nennen. Warum nur habe ich das Gefühl, dass wir über Manchester United sprechen werden?
Manchester United, da weiß man gar nicht, was man sagen soll, ehrlich gesagt. Wir haben gestern im Kollegenkreis nochmal gesprochen. Sportlich brauchen wir ja gar nicht darüber diskutieren. Wir sagen sechs natürlich jetzt nicht gut genug für Manchester United, aber auch nicht katastrophal. Aber die Zustände rundherum, das muss man wirklich sagen. Auch als Kommentatoren, wir haben ja jede Woche, ich habe dann wirklich so eine Rubrik in meinem Vorbereitungsheft da drin gehabt, wo ich einfach nur reingeschrieben habe, was war unter der Woche wieder los. Und das war bahnbrechend, weil einfach der eine kommt nicht zum Training, der andere will nicht trainieren, der andere will nicht in den Kader, der andere will weg. Dann Cristiano Ronaldo schlägt einen Fan und so weiter und so fort. Da gibt es natürlich auch Geschichten, ja, wir haben Mason Greenwood, ich will da gar nicht ins Detail gehen. Cristiano Ronaldo, muss man ja auch nochmal sagen, was da passiert ist mit seiner Familie, also es sind natürlich so viele Geschichten gewesen, dann auch Spieler, die Erkrankungen hatten, irgendwie so psychischer Natur. Es war so viel los in diesem Verein und das hatte Ralf Rangnick alles irgendwo zu managen. Als er kam, war allen klar, wenn Sonscha geht, dann wird natürlich nicht alles gut sein. Aber dass natürlich dann so ein Loch aufbricht, das hätte man wirklich nicht gedacht. Und dass natürlich so ein großes Chaos wird und dass da eine Mannschaft, die so teuer ist, das ist ja einer der teuersten Kader der Welt, ich glaube sogar Top 3, wenn mich alles täuscht, dass der so untergeht in dieser Liga irgendwo und dann am Schluss wirklich auch gar nichts mehr hinbekommt. Das hätte ich wirklich so nicht für möglich gehalten. Wir dachten alle, die würden eigentlich Vierter werden, weil sie weiter wären als Tottenham und als Arsenal. Das ist wirklich eine Katastrophe. Sportlich jetzt, natürlich brauchen wir nicht reden, auch dass sie ein Torverhältnis von Null haben, als Sechster, das ist Wahnsinn. Auf jeden Fall brauchen wir nicht reden, aber das kriege ich vielleicht sogar noch einigermaßen emotionslos mir verkauft, warum es so gelaufen ist. Aber die Umstände, in denen es passiert ist, das ist überhaupt nicht Manchester United würdig. Überhaupt nicht, weil ihr wisst es ja wahrscheinlich selber noch, wenn ihr früher mal überlegt habt, David Gill und Sir Alex Ferguson, da war immer klar, wenn die was machen, dann wusste es keiner davor. Bei Manchester United wussten es alle schon, und dann kamen die erst auf die Idee, was zu machen. Katastrophe, also wirklich eine Katastrophe.
Und wie würdest du im Nachhinein... Ja, warte, lass kurz noch bei United bleiben. Wie würdest du jetzt dann die Zeit von Ralf Rangnick kurz noch bewerten? Also er hatte wenig Chancen, aber hatte er denn mit irgendetwas, was er getan hat, auch Erfolg? Weil, wenn ich ehrlich bin, sind bei mir immer nur die Negativ-Dinge aufgeschlagen, aber das kann ja auch an mir liegen.
Wir haben ja auch so ein bisschen Kontakt zu Manchester United gehabt. Also am Anfang muss man sagen, er hat was so... Also er hat gesagt, er will defensiv erst mal sicherer stehen. Die haben unter Social, glaube ich, im Schnitt 2,5 kassiert ungefähr. 2,3, irgendwas. Das ist natürlich... Ralf Rangnick ist natürlich clever genug, dass er weiß, in der Premier League kriegst du das nicht Woche für Woche hin, dass du das mal übertrumpfst. Das heißt, du musstest ein bisschen stabiler stehen gegen Dressing, bla, bla, bla. Das hat er hinbekommen, einigermaßen. Die hatten immer mal 1,0. Man hatte das Gefühl, die würden da runterkommen, langsam, aber sicher. Und dann irgendwann hat man gemerkt, dass er, glaube ich, auch merkt, dass es nichts wird, dass diese Mannschaft einfach für diesen Spielstil nicht gemacht ist. Er ist dann wieder auf das Solskjaer System 4-2-3-1 zurück, war zwischenzeitlich mal ein 4-2-2-2. Da ist er zurück auf dieses 4-2-3-1, weil er gemerkt hat, okay, es ist vielleicht doch das Beste. Er hat den Spielern dann so ein bisschen mehr dieses Vertrauen gegeben, dass sie auch wieder was in die Hand nehmen können. Und dann hat man gemerkt, es gab Verletzte. Das hat natürlich dann noch mal so einen Einbruch gegeben. Und irgendwann kam dann so bei ihm, das hat man auch auf den Pressekonferenzen gemerkt, der Switch von, okay, dieses Boot werde ich aus diesem Hafen nicht mehr rausziehen. Jetzt versuche ich einfach nur meinen zu retten. Und das hat man dann schon gemerkt, dass auf den Pressekonferenzen er schon auch erklärt hat, warum er das gemacht hat und warum nicht. Und dann natürlich auch gesagt hat, der Kader ist maximal schwierig. Die Situation, hat er wirklich gesagt, das ist ein sehr schwieriger Kader. Ich habe kaum einen Trainer gehört, der jemals so was über seinen Kader gesagt hat. Die stellen sich ja automatisch immer davor. Und wir wissen zum Beispiel auch aus einer ganz guten Quelle, dass zum Beispiel die Geschichte mit Marcial war dieselbe mit Cavani. Die waren beide lang verletzt, haben beide eigentlich das Go bekommen vom Mannschaftsarzt und haben beide gesagt, ne, sie fühlen sich aber nicht so. Also die wollten einfach nicht in den Kader rein. Und das sind natürlich Dinge, das geht ja nicht. Also ich habe das eh letztes Mal irgendwo gesagt, wenn diese hochbezahlten Fußballer den schönsten Job der Welt nicht mehr ausüben wollen, dann verliere ich wirklich die Lust an diesen Sport. Dann entfremdet sich es bei mir, ehrlich gesagt. Weil das geht ja wirklich gar nicht. Und da wissen wir, dass er, wenn er festangestellt wäre, sag ich jetzt mal, dass er dann anders reagiert hätte. Aber er wusste natürlich, er muss auch, um seine Reputation irgendwo natürlich nicht zu gefährden, und er ist natürlich dann irgendwo so Part-timer gewesen. Er wusste natürlich, ich lasse die jetzt drin, um da kein Feuer zu entzünden, um da jetzt nicht irgendwie nochmal Ärger zu machen, weil ich bin hier bloß ein halbes Jahr, ich muss jetzt hier auch nicht alles abfackeln, sondern ich versuche einfach, die wieder irgendwie in die Mannschaft reinzubringen, und dann wird es schon irgendwie wieder laufen. Und solche Geschichten hat er als ständig, dass er halt zwischen, ich habe eigentlich gar nichts zu melden, das wissen die Spieler auch, und vielleicht will ich im Club aber nochmal bleiben als Berater, weil es könnte ja Geld bringen und es könnte ja Manchester United sein, und irgendwie will ich aber natürlich auch in dieser Premier League so meine Zeit genießen und United ein ganz gutes Ergebnis bringen. So, dazwischen war er irgendwo gefangen.
Boah, wirklich eine skurril schwierige Situation, aber das ging anderen Trainern vorher ja auch schon so. Du hattest schon angesetzt zu einer weiteren Enttäuschung. Auf wen wolltest du denn hinaus?
Ich wusste, meine Zeit wird kommen, weil ich habe vorher über Carlo Ancelotti gesprochen, und dass ja, dass eine mittelmäßige Saison bei Everton war, oder enttäuschende Saison bei Everton war. Wir wissen, dass dies nicht war. Wir wissen, dass er eigentlich mit dieser Mannschaft vorüberperformt hat. Denn jetzt hat sich gezeigt, wo die Mannschaft eigentlich wirklich steht. Was wir seit Jahren eigentlich schon sagen im Podcast, Click and Rush, dass Everton einfach seit Jahren wird da schlecht gewirtschaftet, seit Jahren wird da schlecht zusammengestellt, und jetzt werden die Beine abgestiegen. Das ist ein Kader, der Nulldynamik über die Außen hat, der Nulldynamik im Mittelfeld hat, der eigentlich einen ganz guten Torhüter hat für Premier League-Verhältnisse, der zwei sehr gute Verteidiger hat, der zwei ordentliche Angreifer hat, und das war's. Und auch nicht mal irgendwie eine Hierarchie oder sowas. Und jetzt dann auch noch einen Trainer bekommen hat, der halt einen großen Namen hat, weil er ein Spieler mal war. Der aber als Trainer merkt man auch, seine Defizite hat. Jetzt haben sie es am Schluss dann noch mal geschafft, in der Liga zu bleiben, weil sich zwei unklügere gefunden haben, nennen wir es mal so. Und das ist der einzige Grund, warum Everton in der Liga geblieben ist. Das ist eigentlich eine Katastrophe, was die gespielt haben in diesem Jahr. Fast abgestiegen zu sein, das muss man sich mal überlegen. Die haben seit Muxiri übernommen, ich glaube 2016, wenn man mich alles täuscht, haben die über 600 Millionen Euro rausgeblasen. Und du steigst fast ab. Das ist also wirklich komplett irre. Du hast jedes Jahr einen neuen Trainer, du hast jedes Jahr eine neue Philosophie. Am meisten Leid tun mir wirklich die Fans, weil auch das liest man in jeder Vorschau wieder. Die hatten unter Ante Lotti zum Beispiel wirklich die Hoffnung, jetzt kommt einer, der wirklich verstand hat, der wirklich weiß was er tut, der wird uns da rausführen. Wir haben so viele Enttäuschungen erlebt, so viele Investitionen hat nicht geklappt, so viele Versprechungen hat nicht geklappt, so viele Besitzer hat nicht geklappt. Jetzt kommt einer, der wird es ernst meinen. Der hat es ein Jahr lang echt ernst gemeint und hat dann gemerkt, warte mal, hier liegt alles brach, schnell weg, schnell zu Jaima Dritt. Und das ist das, was Frank Leppardt aus Baden-Dach hat. Er hat natürlich auch seine Defizite gehabt, ganz klar. Aber das ist wirklich die Enttäuschung schlechthin, vielleicht sogar europaweit. Weil dieser Club hat eigentlich von den finanziellen Möglichkeiten her viel mehr, von den Ausgaben her viel mehr drauf. Und natürlich auch von der Fanschar her viel mehr und auch von der Strahlkraft her. Und das ist so, Uli sagt immer, der Vergleich ist gar nicht so schlecht. Das ist so der HSV der Premier League. Viele reden mit, keiner hat Ahnung. Geld wird trotzdem rausgeworfen. Und dann wundern sich alle, warum nichts bei rumkommt. Wir haben doch investiert. Ja, okay, wenn ich dir sage, Max, geh mal und kauf den Anzug. Und du kommst dann mit fünf Jacken zurück. Dann frag ich dich auch, was hast du eigentlich mit dem Geld gemacht? Und so ist es da halt.
Ich würde gerne mal einen Anzug in deinem Auftrag kaufen. Aber das ist vielleicht eine andere.
Wir gehen mal zusammen shoppen. Das will ich sehen.
Das würden doch so meine andere gerne sehen. Ich bin nicht so... Ich bin nicht so der Shopping-Dub. Du kannst für mich shoppen gehen. Okay, das waren die Enttäuschungen. Marius, ich würde dich gerne als erstes fragen, nach den Spielerneuentdeckungen dieser Saison. Wer sind Spieler, die diese abgelaufenen Serie A Saison ihren Stempel aufdrücken konnten? Und wo man es vorher vielleicht nicht erwartet hätte?
Da muss ich direkt auch wieder zum Meister zu Milan springen. Denn wenn man eine sehr junge Mannschaft hat und am Ende die Meisterschaft gewinnt, dann ist es logisch, dass da auch welche, den direkten Durchbruch in dieser Saison geschafft haben. Und das ist einmal allen voran. Pierre Caloulou, ein Innenverteidiger, der vor anderthalb oder zwei Jahren aus Lyon gekommen ist, da noch kein einziges Profi-Spiel gemacht hat. Und so ein bisschen eigentlich als Backup für die rechtsverteidigende Position, als Talent. Den bauen wir vielleicht mal so langsam und behutsam aufgeholt wurde. Und der dieses Jahr so im Spätherbst rum plötzlich in die erste Mannschaft reingeworfen werden musste, weil sich mit Simon Kehr, der der große alte weise Mann quasi in der Innenverteidigung bei Milan einen Kreuzbandriss zugezogen hat und der Kapitän Romagnoli auch verletzt war. Und ja, dann gab es quasi keinen anderen mehr. Und dann ist eben Carlou Loup da reingezogen worden und hat an der Seite von Fikaio Tomori eine unfassbare Entwicklung hingenommen, also hingelegt. Habe ich in der Serie A von einem Verteidiger in den jungen Jahren, weiß ich nicht mehr, wann ich das das letzte Mal gesehen habe, also nächstes Jahr hoffentlich dann auch als Stammkraft in der Champions League, kann man sich dann auch nicht Serie A-Fans davon überzeugen. Ist ein weiteres unglaublich großes französisches Talent und hat also, ja, meinen Mind geblut.
Aber er wird in die Premier League wechseln, habe ich das jetzt gerade richtig rausgehört?
Nein, Champions League habe ich Premier League gesagt. Ich hoffe, er wechselt noch nicht in die Premier League. Aber wegen Geldern und so kann das natürlich in den nächsten Jahren irgendwann mal der Fall sein.
Ja, ja, gut, das kann passieren. Aber es ist gut, also Champions League war gemeint. Wen gibt es denn darüber hinaus noch?
Mein MVP der Saison ist eigentlich Raphael Leao, also auch ein Milan-Spieler. Der ist natürlich vorher schon bekannt gewesen, hat aber in dieser Saison den Sprung zum wirklich alles entscheidenden Offensivspieler bei Milan gemacht, auch jetzt gerade in der Saison-Schlussphase eigentlich an allen Toren mehr oder weniger direkt beteiligt gewesen. Und es würde mich nicht überraschen, wenn man ihn zum Spieler der Saison wählt. Und abgesehen davon gibt es noch so ein paar andere Talente. Bei Udinese gibt es ein Destiny-Odojie und Jean-Victor Mackengo. Das sind zwei Mittelfeld- bzw. Außenspieler, die auf jeden Fall in den nächsten Jahren den Schritt zu Top-Vereinen machen werden. Bei Atalanta tatsächlich auch. Die Verletzungsprobleme hatte ich angesprochen. Da hat sich Giorgio Scalvini hervorgetan, ein ganz junger Innenverteidiger, italienischer Unnationalspieler. Dem könnte ich mir auch vorstellen, dass er nächstes Jahr direkt mit Anfang 20 zum Stammpersonal gehören wird. Ich habe sie als positive Überraschung extra nicht vergessen, sondern wollte das –wir kommen ja auch noch auf Anekdoten zu sprechen –da wollte ich dann was zu Ues Salenitana sagen. Aber da muss man auch eine Spielerentdeckung auf jeden Fall erwähnen. Das ist Ederson, ein brasilianischer Mittelfeldspieler, den sie erst im Winter verpflichtet haben und der wirklich maßgeblichen Anteil daran hatte, dass dieser Verein aus einer absolut aussichtslosen Situation noch den Klassenerhalt geschafft hat.
Sehr schön. Salenitana hatte ich mir nämlich noch aufgeschrieben, dass ich danach noch frage. Alex, wer hat in La Liga zur Überraschung aller überzeugt? Da muss man –man kommt nicht drum herum –man muss einfach Gavi nennen, den 17-jährigen Shootingstar des FC Barcelona. Und den erwähne ich jetzt nicht, weil ich dem FC Barcelona recht nahe stehe, sondern wer mit 17 aus der Jugend direkt in die 1. Mannschaft kommt. Also er hat die 2. Mannschaft, Barca B, die in der 3. Liga spielt, übersprungen. Normalerweise ist ja der Weg so, dass du aus der B-Jugend, A-Jugend dann in die 2. Mannschaft kommst, da in der 3. Liga spielst. Und dann, wenn du das Talent hast, hochgezogen wird. Nee, er hat die Barca B, die 2. Mannschaft übersprungen, kam direkt zu den Profis und jetzt kommt es. Wettbewerbsübergreifend, 47 Einsätze. Nur 2 Barca-Spieler haben, also 47, die Zahl an sich ist ja eh verrückt, aber nur 2 Spieler haben mehr. Sergio Busquets, 51 Spiele. Marc-Andrej Ter Stegen, der Stammtorhüter, die Nummer 1, 49 Spiele. Dann kommt schon der 17-jährige Gavi. Also das ist absolut unbegreiflich, um ehrlich zu sein, wie so jemand nicht nur ab und zu Einsätze bekommt. So wie beispielsweise Jamal Musiale bei den Bayern. Wird mal hier eingewechselt, mal da. Dann gelingt ihm natürlich tolle Sachen. Nee, der wurde direkt Stammspieler und hat die drittmeisten Spiele in der Saison absolviert für Barca. Also ein absoluter Eckpfeiler. Und vor allem nicht nur als Joker, sondern in La Liga hat er 28-mal in der Startelf gestanden. Das ist einfach, das ist richtig krass. Am Ende, ich glaube, 2 Tore, 6 Assists. Also die Zahlen sind jetzt auch nicht so schlecht. Wohlgemerkt als 17-Jähriger, der nicht mal 3. Liga gespielt hat. Davor wirklich nur in der Jugend. Deswegen ist das die Spielerneuentdeckung wirklich im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes. Nummer 1 sind die anderen Spieler, die ich jetzt so in der Folge wahrscheinlich nennen will, oder muss, weil du ja mehrere Spieler nennst, die sind ja nicht neu in dem Sinne, sondern die waren ja alle schon entweder in La Liga im Einsatz oder in anderen Ligen. Und wer kommt da noch so? Also für mich so ein kleiner Shootingstar der Saison oder so der, ja, most improved player, um da in dem NBA-Rhythmus zu bleiben, Vinicius Junior bei Real Madrid, eine enorme Entwicklung vorgenommen. Ist jetzt natürlich europäisch gesehen oder generell kein unbekannter, klar. Hat aber wirklich einen tollen Schwung gemacht. Am Ende 17 Tore und 10 Assists in La Liga geschossen, hätte ich ihm so niemals zugetraut, weil er als absoluter Chancentod eigentlich bekannt war. Also wirklich, der vor dem Tor, so blöd das klingt, das klingt jetzt ein bisschen nach Doppelpass, aber der kein Scheuntor trifft vor der Kiste normalerweise, dass er jetzt nicht nur zweistellig trifft, ist schon klasse, und ich hätte ihm so nicht zugetraut. Wirklich 17 Tore, 10 Assists, auch enorm wichtige Tore geschossen, Traumtore geschossen. Also unter Ancelotti da wirklich eine enorme Entwicklung vorgenommen, einen tollen Leistungssprung und so ein bisschen der Shooting-Star. Denn der andere ist ja logisch, also Karin Benzema über den brauchen wir wirklich nicht sprechen. Nee, und den lass ich auch als Neuentdeckung nicht mehr durchgehen. Den kannst du nicht durchgehen lassen, nee. Einfallen würde man natürlich, Usman Dembelé, passt natürlich auch nicht zum Thema Neuentdeckung, aber man muss ganz kurz erwähnen, dass er die meisten Assists in La Liga hinbekommen hat. 13 Assists in, Achtung, 21 Ligaspielen nur. Wie viele davon aus dem Krankenhaus heraus? Das ist es ja, er ist ja ab und zu mal verletzt in 21 Spielen 13 Assists. Ich bin jetzt in Mathe nicht so bewandert, aber wenn man das mal auf 38 Spiele hochrechnen würde, oder lasst es 35 sein, das wäre ein ziemlich guter Wert. Also es ist ja so schon, er ist ja der Beste in der Saison. Aber Tor kann er immer noch nicht schießen, ich glaube, ein mickriges Saison-Törchen. Aber 13 Assists auch nicht so schlecht. Also auch ein Player to watch ohne Assist ablösefrei. Von daher, ja, anderes Thema. Von daher nur 300 Millionen Handgeld. Gut, das waren die Spielerneuentdeckungen. Alex, du... Ach nee, Entschuldigung. Jogi muss natürlich noch. Sorry, Jogi. Jetzt fängt es schon an. Da lässt meine Kondition nach am Ende der Saison. So ehrlich müssen wir sein. Wen gibt es denn in der Premier League noch zu nennen?
Ja, es gibt mit Sicherheit so Spieler, die natürlich den nächsten Schritt gemacht haben, so in die Weltspitze, wo ich jetzt echt interessiert bin dran. Was machen die? Zum Beispiel so ein Declan Rice bin ich jetzt sehr gespannt, der auch schon angekündigt hat, dass er den Club verlassen möchte. Dass einer, der noch mal einen Schritt gemacht hat, noch mal ein bisschen erwachsener geworden ist, auch noch mal dem Mann immer nachgesagt, da kann ich mit dem Ball so umgehen. Das ist jetzt der Spieler, der Mittelfeldspieler, der die meisten Dribblings in den Raum rein hat, also in nach vorne. Also jemand, der wirklich noch mal technisch viel besser geworden ist, die Passquote erhöht hat. Da bin ich richtig gespannt, ob für den jemand richtig Geld hinlegen wird, weil dann wären es wirklich so über 100. Da bin ich echt mal gespannt, da hat David Moyes gesagt, es gibt Spieler, die sind über 100 Millionen Euro gewechselt, die können Decker und Rice nicht mal die Schuhe binden. Dann sind wir mal gespannt, für wie viel der weggeht. Das ist sicherlich eine sehr interessante Geschichte. Aber dann gibt es natürlich Typen wie Gerald Bone zum Beispiel, bei dem viele gesagt haben, das wäre der most improved player, der in dieser Saison 12 Tore, 10 Assists gemacht hat. Der hat am Schluss jetzt noch mal so eine kleine Phase gehabt, wo es schwächer war, dann wurde es wieder besser. Aber der hat einen Zeitgang mal wirklich so ausgesehen, als wäre er der nächste, den vielleicht Liverpool mal holen möchte oder so etwas in Richtung. Das war mit Sicherheit jemand. Und dann gibt es halt noch so kleinere Spieler, wie zum Beispiel eben so ein Jacob Ramsey, der sich entwickelt hat bei Eston Villa, der eine Chance bekommen hat. Marco Correa, der, glaube ich, auch in Spanien, werdet ihr mit Sicherheit besser wissen, aber der dort jetzt nicht so der allergrößte war, der von Barcelona einen weg ist, einen Schritt nach zurück gemacht hat, dort aber jetzt richtig gut performt hat, einer der besten Linksverteidiger der Liga geworden ist. Und dann Conor Gallagher, den haben alle genannt, der von Chelsea verliehen hat an Crystal Palace, dort aber gezeigt, dass er einfach so ein giftiger Spieler ist, immer 120 Prozent gibt, trotzdem fußballerisch echt auch wirklich ordentlich ist, das ist auch nochmal so eine Entwicklung. Luis Diaz, Top-Neu-Verpflichtung, mit dem viele nicht gerechnet hätten, und dann natürlich Christian Eriksen, also dass der natürlich auch nochmal zurückkommt und dann aber sofort wieder dieses Level aufrufen kann, das hätte ich wirklich nicht gedacht, weil viele schon gemeint hätten, der spielt vielleicht nur noch, in Anführungszeichen, Fußball, weil es halt Spaß macht, aber der hat mit Sicherheit nicht mehr so diesen Drive und vielleicht schonet er sich auch, gab es schon so hinter vorgehaltener Hand so die Vermutungen. Ganz im Gegenteil, der ist so unfassbar gut, also ich habe Brent Ford, der hat die nochmal komplett auf ein neues Level gehielt, weil der einfach eine Sache perfekt macht, der nimmt den Ball, dreht sich und spielt ihn immer nach vorne, genau zum richtigen. Mal lang, mal kurz, aber es hat immer Sinn und es gibt immer Tiefe. Ein unfassbar intelligenter Spieler. Das sind so die Entdeckungen, würde ich mal sagen. Oder ja, Wiederentdeckungen, sagen wir bei Ericson mal.
Ja, aber schön, dass du ihn noch mit reingenommen hast. Das finde ich passt hier sehr gut. Wer waren denn für dich dann so die entscheidenden Trainer in dieser Saison?
Ja gut, Pepp und Klopp sind einfach wirklich herausragende Trainer, das muss man einfach sagen. Graham Potter haben wir schon mal angeschnitten gehabt. Aber meine Entdeckung, ich habe letztens im Spiel gesagt, der hätte wahrscheinlich sogar die Wirecard gerettet. Eddie Howe, der aus Newcastle, die waren ganz unten, da hat keiner mehr mit irgendwas gerechnet. Steve Bruce, der hat die wirklich zugrundegerichtet, taktisch, und dann kommt der dahin, sieht die ersten Spiele auch nicht gut aus, und man denkt sich so, okay, ist dieser Hype schon wieder weg, und dann fängt der an, mit denen zu arbeiten, und du erkennst in jedem Spiel, zu aller Konte, ja, ist es eine Organisation da, ja, okay, ich gebe diesem Team auf jeden Fall das, was es braucht, mehr haben wir noch nicht, aber wir sind zumindest mal kompakt, wir sind organisiert, und dann hoffen wir mal, dass zwei, drei irgendwie durchrutschen, bei Standards oder bei Kontern, und genau das hat funktioniert, er hat genau wirklich gemerkt, dass er hat nur diese Spielertypen, er lässt jetzt so spielen, das war ja in Bournemouth komplett anders, das war ja wirklich technischer Fußball, bei Newcastle war es eher so, okay, ich habe keine anderen Typen momentan, Momentan, wir haben wirklich nur diese zwei Mechanismen, entweder Standards oder Schnelligkeit und dann versuchen wir das irgendwie zu nutzen. Und genau so hat sich's ausgezahlt, und am Ende sind die elfter geworden. Damit hätte keiner mehr gerechnet im Winter. Und das ist wirklich das Makeover der Saison auf jeden Fall. Auch wenn natürlich das jetzt nicht unbedingt viele romantische Gefühle bei dem ein oder anderen hervorbeschwören wird, weil aufgrund der finanziellen Struktur des Clubs, die jetzt da ist, aber das ist wirklich beeindruckend, das aus dieser Mannschaft so gemacht zu haben.
Ja, wirklich interessant, was sich da bei Newcastle getan hat in dieser Saison. Marius, in der Serie A, da laufen so viele interessante Trainer um. Eigentlich in allen drei liegen, über die wir gerade sprechen, möchte ich jetzt gar nicht hier einen Unterschied aufmachen. Aber wer war denn in der Saison für dich besonders hervorzuheben?
Auch hier muss ich dann erst mal natürlich direkt wieder zum Milan springen, denn der Meistertrainer Stefano Pioli, als der vor zweieinhalb Jahren bei Milan übernommen hat, da haben die Fans eigentlich so gesagt, okay, vielleicht macht er mit uns jetzt die Saison noch zu Ende und dann schauen wir mal, dann hauen wir hoffentlich jemanden, der uns wirklich nach oben führen kann. Dann sind ja auch mit Ralf Rangnick Gespräche geführt worden. Aber er hatte die Mannschaft seitdem schon so erreicht und um sich gescharrt, dass ein Zlatan Ibrahimov sich zum Beispiel im Interview gesagt hat, wir müssen mit dem verlängern, sonst bin ich auch weg zum Beispiel. Und wie er sich in den letzten Jahren, also seit er bei Milan ist, entwickelt hat, wie er auch sich taktisch weiterentwickelt hat und was er vor allem auch menschlich für eine große Person ist, das hat er damals in Florenz schon gezeigt, als da wieder Astori gestorben ist, wie er da mit der Mannschaft umgegangen ist und jetzt auch diese junge Mannschaft entwickelt, angeleitet hat, eben was er taktisch daraus gemacht hat. Auf jeden Fall der Trainer, der dieser Saison seinen Stempel aufgedrückt hat. Dann habe ich von Hellas und Torino, Juric und Tudor, die habe ich erwähnt. Und dann bin ich dann auch wieder bei Salenitana, die ich eben erwähnt hatte, da hat Davide Nicola erst im Januar übernommen. Da hatte die Mannschaft glaube ich 9 Punkte auf dem Konto und er hat noch geschafft 21 Punkte oder so zu holen. Die sind jetzt bei 31 rausgekommen, haben die Klasse gehalten. Und das ist eine unglaubliche Geschichte. Und er ist, also wenn Felix Magath, der archätypische Feuerwehrmann, ist jetzt vielleicht dann nicht mehr, wenn er heute Abend absteigt, dann ist es Davide Nicola auf jeden Fall in Italien.
Mal gucken, ob du da jetzt nicht gerade etwas gejinkst hast, was das Relegationsrückspiel angeht, das wir heute Abend sehen werden. Alex, wen hast du bei dir auf der Liste als Trainer des Jahres im weitesten Sinne? Also Trainer des Jahres, wahrscheinlich würde ich da Pellegrini wählen, weil er den Pokal mit Betis gewonnen hat, was ein historisches Achievement war. Und weil er ja auch so mit Blick auf La Liga ja auch fünfter geworden ist, ist es auch eine richtig tolle Saison, um Einheim die Champions League eingezogen. Es ist einfach schwer, die Top 4 da oben drüber von ihrem Vier, von dem Thron, von den vier Trönen zu stoßen. Schiefes Bild jetzt. Also eine tolle Saison gespielt, mit dem Pokalsieg sich gekrönt. Den würde ich wahrscheinlich nennen. Aber ich möchte viel mehr Raum zwei Trainern zukommen lassen, die so gar nicht im Blickpunkt der Öffentlichkeit sind, erst recht nicht in Deutschland, aber auch nicht mal in Spanien. Denn zwei Trainer, die mit ihren Mannschaften die Klasse gehalten haben, die aber als Feuerwehrmänner kamen und wirklich ihren Job besser nicht hätten machen können. Sergio González hat Cádiz in der Liga gehalten, hat das im Januar das Amt von Alvaro Severa übernommen und von 18 Spielen nur fünf verloren, dabei drei gegen Top-6-Teams. Unter anderem hat er aber viele andere Top-Teams schlagen können oder ärgern können. Also beispielsweise im Camp Nou gewonnen gegen Villarreal gewonnen, Real Madrid einen Punkt abgetrotzt und auch dem FC Sevilla einen Punkt abgetrotzt. Und so eben als Trainer von Cádiz, mit Cádiz am letzten Spieltag die Klasse gehalten, hätte ich persönlich so nicht für möglich gehalten, weil er eine Saison vorher mit Valladolid mehr oder minder sang und klanglos abgestiegen ist. Deswegen war ich auch nicht so überzeugt von der Trainer-Einstellung von Cádiz, um ehrlich zu sein, hätte ihnen das nicht zugetraut, dass sie die Klasse halten. Hat er aber toll gemacht. Punkteschnitt von 1,39, Sergio. F11-pester Punkteschnitt aller La Liga-Trainer mit einem Bottom-3-Team. Zum Vergleich, nur damit man ein bisschen eine Perspektive hat, mit Blick auf die Bundesliga-Bowl-Svenson, der einen phänomenalen Job mit Mainz gemacht hat, der ja 8er wurde in Mainz, hat den gleichen Punkteschnitt, 1,39. Der Bo-Svenson der spanischen Meisterschaft, das ist auch schön. Ja, das hast du jetzt gesagt. Aber nur um eine Perspektive ein bisschen zu haben, mit einem Abstiegsteam, so eine tolle Leistung zu liefern, ist wirklich toll. Und ähnliche Kategorie ist das, was Javier Aguirre gemacht hat. Der alte Fahrernsmann, jetzt kommst du wieder mit der Felix Maggaten Mexikos. Er liegt aber nahe, war ja früher Mexikonationaltrainer, keine Ahnung, wie viele Stationen in den letzten 20 Jahren, kam auch hinten raus für die letzten neun Spiele bei Mallorca und hat nur vier dieser neun Spiele verloren. Die letzten drei ungeschlagen, davon die letzten zwei gewonnen und sich so am letzten Spieltag gerettet. Also auch eine richtig, richtig tolle Leistung gezeigt. Da haben die Feuerwehrmänner funktioniert. Er hat einen Punkteschnitt von 1,44 in diesen neun Spielen. Zehn bester Punkteschnitt aller Ligatrainer. Nur um das ein bisschen in Perspektive zu setzen. Also zwei Feuerwehrmänner oder zwei Trainer-Einstellungen, die absolut perfekt funktioniert haben für zwei sehr kleine, vom Abstiegs bedrohte Clubs. Das sollte man schon auch lobend erwähnen, denn klappt ja nicht immer so ein Trainerwechsel.
Also der Steffen Baumgrad von der Liga kann man das so sagen.
Ja, wie gesagt, Aguirre ist ja 75 oder so, deswegen ein ziemlicher Wandervogel zuletzt gewesen. Deswegen der Vergleich mit Magath. Irgendeinen müssen wir jetzt nehmen. So ein harter Hund ist ja auch bekannt, also hat viel Erfahrung natürlich, aber ist eher als so harter Hund und Schleifer, der dann halt meinetwegen auch mit 20 Prozent Ballbesitz und drei Torschützen irgendwie in 1-0 outgrindet. Aber es kann eben reichen, wenn die Mannschaft das adaptiert, was er macht. Letztes Jahr hat er beinahe Leganes in der Liga gehalten, da hat es ganz, ganz knapp nicht geklappt. Dieses Jahr hat Mallorca gesagt, das hat uns gefallen, was der letzte Mal als Feuerwehrmann gemacht hat, haben sie ihn eingestellt und er hat die Klasse gehalten. Also alles richtig gemacht, Mallorca und Cardis. Überhaupt ein spannendes Saisonfinale, was den Abstiegskampf angeht. Mallorca und Cardis haben sich gerettet, Granada noch abgerutscht auf den 18. Tabellenplatz. Ja, sehr dramatisch gestern. Ja, das ist allerdings wahr. Wenn wir ein bisschen versuchen, in die Zukunft zu schauen, mit Blick auf die nächste Saison, was glaubst du, wer wird in der Zukunft für Furore sorgen in La Liga? Gibt es da einen Geheimtipp? Boah, da sind wir wieder beim Thema. Eigentlich ist die Tabelle ziemlich festgefahren. Wenn du mich heute fragen würdest, wie lauten die Top 7 nächstes Jahr, ich würde sagen, genauso wie dieses Jahr. Ja, leider eine langweilige Antwort, aber Real Madrid, Barca, Atletico und Sevilla sind so viel besser normalerweise als die Konkurrenz. Betis wäre fast dran gewesen, da in die Top 4 zu kommen, aber es braucht halt auch sehr, sehr schwache Enttäuschung der Saisons von Barca, Atletico und Sevilla, damit die Top 4 geknackt werden können. Alle drei waren sehr enttäuschend in dem Jahr, haben underperformed, haben schlecht gespielt, haben wenig Punkte geholt und trotzdem hat es für Betis nicht gereicht. Deswegen, was soll da Hoffnung machen? Also ich fürchte, so viel wird sich nächstes Jahr da nicht wirklich ändern und ja, ob jetzt Real, Barca oder Atletico Meister wird, ich glaube für den geneigten deutschen Zuschauer ist das jetzt auch nicht so die prickelnde Vorhersage. Okay, dann muss ich dir gleich die Frage danach stellen, was wird dir denn in Erinnerung bleiben, auch noch in drei, vier, fünf Jahren von dieser Saison? Gibt es unvergessliche Anekdoten? Also ich möchte wieder zurück zu Manuel Pellegrini, denn es gab wirklich eine spannende Anekdote, und zwar seine Trainingsanzug-Marotte. Statistik-Freunde haben herausgefunden, dass er 63 Prozent der Spiele gewinnt, wenn er einen alten, nicht ganz so schönen Kappa-Trainingsanzug stellt. Er trägt, er gestellt von der Mannschaft von Bethes. Sieht so ein bisschen aus wie so ein Trainingsanzug, den sie in den 90ern im Kick zu kaufen gab. Also 63 Prozent der Spiele gewinnt er, wenn er dieses Ding trägt. Er gewinnt aber nur 39 Prozent der Spiele, wenn er ihn nicht trägt. Und was hat er dann im Pokalfinale gemacht, wo man sich ja normalerweise fein in den Anzug anzieht? Er hat im Pokalfinale dieses Ding getragen, seinen Trainingsanzug und hat den Pokal damit gewonnen. Also Aberglaube hat sich durchgesetzt. Historisches Achievement mit seinem Trainingsanzug als Marotte. Das ist so für mich die Anekdote der Saison gewesen. Und wir alle wissen natürlich, dass er damit der Udo Lattek von La Liga ist. Immer diese Vergleiche. Ich habe noch hinten draußen einen verrückten, aber witzigen Statistikrekord. Iñaki Williams hat sechs Jahre lang in Folge kein einziges Spiel verpasst. Wir sprechen von 233 Spielen in Folge absoluter La Liga-Rekord. Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie die Rekorde in anderen Ligen sind. Vielleicht weiß das der eine oder andere. Also in Deutschland ist es Sepp Mayer mit 445 glaube ich. Aber in Folge? Genau, in Folge tatsächlich auch. Nie verletzt, nie krank, nie allein im Zeitalter von Corona. Jetzt ist das ja besonders, dass du nicht mal ein, zwei Wochen mit Corona ausfällst. Nicht mal das. Letztmals hat er gefehlt im April 2016. Das muss man sich mal vorstellen. Nicht schlecht.
Wahnsinn, die gerade Christian Günther vom SC Freiburg mit Andi 120 spielen, glaube ich, vorne.
Richtig krass.
Das liebe ich, dass man uns einfach unsere bescheuerte Statistiken hinwerfen kann. Und da blühen wir auf einmal alle auf. Da blühen sie alle auf. Aber sechs Jahre in Folge, kein Spiel verpassen. Wie geht denn so was? Ich habe es zu Nils vorhin im Podcast gesagt. Und wenn du dir mal am, weiß ich nicht, am Tisch irgendwie den kleinen C stößt und das passiert dann Freitagabend oder ich verpasse das Spiel am Samstag oder Sonntag, das wäre völlig normal. Aber nicht mal das. Also wirklich, wirklich krass. Und er ist Stürmer und ziemlich schneller. Ja genau, das wollte ich gerade sagen, er ist jetzt nicht Torhüter oder so. Genau, er ist nicht Torhüter oder ein Verteidiger, sondern er ist Stürmer ziemlich schnell. Die sind ja normalerweise anfällig für Muskelverletzungen. Grüße an den Belé und Hazard und Bale und Co. Der hat nichts, der Typ. Ich weiß nicht, wie er das schafft. Also absoluter Wahnsinn. Das ist wirklich eine sehr, sehr bemerkenswerte Statistik.
Das muss man sagen.
So, Yogi, dann darfst du jetzt noch uns liefern. Wer wird für Furore sorgen und woran wirst du dich immer erinnern?
Ich habe gerade überlegt, woran ich mich immer erinnern werde. Das ist echt für mich schwierig. Diese Anekdoten, würde ich echt sagen, bin ich echt schlecht drin. Es gibt natürlich sicherlich so Dinge. Das Jahr haben wir schon besprochen, wo wir uns auf jeden Fall erinnern werden. Das ist die Geschichte mit Newcastle United, dass die übernommen haben. Das kann man dann auch verknüpfen. Ich glaube, dass die im nächsten Jahr schon für Furore sorgen werden. Ob die jetzt gleich in die Top 6 reinbrechen, das weiß ich nicht. Aber ich tippe, 7, 8 wird schon möglich sein. Ich bin gespannt, was die im Sommer machen. Das ist mit Sicherheit das, worauf wir achten müssen. Die werden für Furore sorgen. Die Frage ist, kann Ten Hag wirklich etwas umdrehen? Wir haben gestern im Kollegenkreis gewitselt, dass die einzige Liga der Welt, in der du es hinbekommst, einen Umbruch zu schaffen und trotzdem Meister zu werden, die Bundesliga ist. Das ist in Englisch gnadenlos. Es könnte wirklich sein, dass, wenn er zu viel umreißt, dass er ein Problem bekommt, denn die sind jetzt schon Sechster. Was ist denn, wenn die umbrechen und er die Hälfte der Mannschaft austauscht und es nicht gleich funktioniert? Was ist, wenn die Elfter werden? Dreht dann alle durch, wie er bei Gang 6 jetzt schon durchgedreht wird. Das könnte negative Furore sein, New Class könnte die in Anführungszeichen positive Furore werden. Und dann so Anekdoten. Da gibt es natürlich schon so viele lustige Dinge, die durch passiert sind irgendwo. Aber so die ganz großen Dinge, ehrlich gesagt, fallen mir jetzt momentan gerade nicht ein. Bin ich gerade echt am überlegen, aber bin ich raus, glaube ich.
Da musst du dir auch nichts aus der Nase ziehen, weil sonst ist es ja auch keine richtige bedenkenswerte Anekdote. Dann bleibt uns nur noch der Blick nach Italien. Marius, wer wird in der nächsten Saison für Furore sorgen? Woran wirst du dich für immer erinnern?
Was ich hoffe und woran ich auch fest glaube, ist, dass in seinem zweiten Jahr Jose Mourinho aus der Roma ein Team machen wird, das vielleicht nicht bis ganz zum Schluss, aber zumindest lange Strecken der Saison ein Kandidat sein wird, wo wir uns darüber unterhalten werden, ob sie vielleicht mal Meister werden können. Also ich finde, es ist ja bei ihm immer so ein bisschen zweischneidig. Auch als er die Roma übernommen hat, da dachten sie, okay, jetzt ist bei ihm, Tottenheim war schon nicht mehr so groß und jetzt kommt die Roma, das ist noch mal eine Stufe darunter, jetzt ist bei ihm der Lack irgendwie komplett ab. Aber er hat gezeigt, erst mal, dass er auch in der Lage ist, taktisch sich noch weiterentwickeln zu können. Er lässt bei der Roma keinen typischen Mourinho-Fußball aus den letzten 20 Jahren spielen, sondern lässt da einen offensiven Ball spielen. Das ist auch teilweise sehr gefällig, mit Tammy Abraham einen super Stürmer geholt, der 17. Saisontore geschossen hat. Ich glaube, wenn die Mannschaft noch ein bisschen gefestigter ist, wenn sie im Sommer noch ein, zwei Verstärkungen dazu bekommen, dass sie auf jeden Fall nächste Saison die Champions League-Plätze und vielleicht auch mit ein bisschen Glück hinten raus ganz oben angreifen können. Und da passt das dann eigentlich auch anekdotisch, weiß ich jetzt nicht, aber auch statistisch, dass er jetzt ja am Mittwoch noch die Chance hat, der erste Trainer zu werden, der alle drei aktuellen Pokale dann aus der Van der Wever gewonnen haben werden könnte. Weil er ja noch im Conference-Finale gegen Feyenoord steht. Und das ist natürlich, Mourinho kommt irgendwo hin und sagt, ich hole euch Silverware und dann schafft er das bei der Roma, die seit 2000 keinen Titel mehr gewonnen hat. Das ist natürlich dann auch eine nette Geschichte. Was auf jeden Fall auch in Erinnerung bleiben wird, ist, dass der Milan-Titel eigentlich, da haben dann viele Leute gesagt, jetzt ist es klar, als am vergangenen, also vor anderthalb Wochen, am vorletzten Spieltag, Theo Hernandez aus einem 100-Meter-Sprint heraus, dass das entscheidende Tor geschossen hat gegen Atalanta. Das wird in jedem Jahresrückblicks-Video in Italien auf jeden Fall die Szene sein. Und Anekdote auf jeden Fall auch. Salenitana, wie sie sich gerettet haben, habe ich gerade ja schon kurz gesagt, wie Davide Nicolai da den Turnaround geschafft hat. Absolut, absoluter Wahnsinn im Grunde genommen. Die haben im Winter eine komplett neue Elf gekauft, also einen Torwart und zehn neue Spieler. Die haben nicht immer so komplett zusammengespielt, aber sie haben quasi den Kader nochmal komplett umgekrempelt und haben eben damit den Klassen halt geschafft. Und er hat vor ein paar Wochen gesagt, wenn wir es schaffen, dann laufe ich zu Fuß zum Vatikan und zum Papst. Und ich weiß nicht, ob er heute schon auf dem Weg ist mit ein bisschen Restalkohol oder ob das jetzt die Tage in Angriff nimmt. Von Salerno aus sind das so 250, 300 Kilometer, glaube ich. Er macht das auf jeden Fall. Er hat mit Crotone schon mal eine sehr wahnsinnige Rettungsaktion gestartet. Er kommt aus dem Piemont, aus der Nähe von Turin. Und ist dann von Crotone, das ist so an der Sohle des Stiefels quasi. Ist aber mit dem Fahrrad einmal hochgefahren nach Turin, nach ganz oben. Also er hat da gezeigt, dass er diese Ankündigungen wahr macht. Und das finde ich auf jeden Fall auch erinnerungswürdig.
Ihr drei, dann haben wir es doch geschafft. Ich danke euch dreien ganz herzlich und stellvertretend auch noch mal in Abwesenheit allen anderen. Zum einen für die Premier League waren in diesem Jahr mit dabei. Uli Hebel, Hendrik Buchheister und herzlichen Dank jetzt stellvertretend an dich. Jogi Hebel, danke, dass du hier mit dabei warst. Ja, mir ebenso. Und herzlichen Dank an für La Liga. Fabian Pakulat, Nies Kern und jetzt Alex Truica. Alex, danke, dass du diese etwas längere Sendung auf dich genommen hast. Sehr gerne, es ist mir immer eine Freude und Ehre, hier dabei zu sein. Macht immer großen Spaß, danke. Ja, das werden wir auf jeden Fall weitermachen. Mir macht es auch richtig viel Spaß, muss ich sagen. Und herzlichen Dank an Christian Bernhard von der Serie A, Mario Rieker für die Serie A und natürlich jetzt auch Marius Soyke, die man, also euch kann man ja auch bei Serie Amore hören. Überhaupt euch alle kann man hören, das habe ich jetzt gar nicht geplagt. Also Click and Rush natürlich für die Premier League, den Tiki Taka Podcast für La Liga und Serie Amore für die Serie A. Danke dir, lieber Marius, dass du hier mit dabei warst.
Danke dir, Max, für die Einladung. Ich schließe mich den beiden Kollegen an. Es macht großen Spaß, hier dabei zu sein und gerne nächste Saison wieder.
Ja, wenn es nach mir geht, auf jeden Fall. Und wir machen an dieser Stelle jetzt weiter mit Alexis Menuge und der Ligue A. Jetzt habe ich Alexis Menuge bei mir zur Ligue A noch am Sonntagabend. Es ist noch alles ganz frisch. Alexis, wie hoch ist dein Puls? Und schön, dass du hier bist.
Danke, Max, freue mich auch. Der Puls war vor allem am Samstagabend richtig hoch, weil wir hatten den letzten Spieltag der Ligue 1-Saison und zehn Spiele parallel, 35 Treffer. Wir hatten ja in der Ligue 1, waren wir gewohnt, vor zehn Jahren noch viele 0-0 zu haben. 2,1, 2,2 Tore pro Spielung dieser Saison haben wir im Endeffekt 2,85. Das ist der beste Wert seit 2002. Ich durfte gestern wieder so an Lens Monaco kommentieren, Ausgleich in der Nachspielzeit für Lens. Monaco war sicher auf dem zweiten Platz, und auf einmal kommt dieser Ausgleich, und dadurch rutscht der Marseille auf Platz zwei und darf also direkt in die Champions League starten im September, wer in Monaco zwei Quali-Runde überstehen muss. Aber natürlich die große Nachricht war, dass der Mbappé, das Kapitel war seine Zukunft anbelangt, ist endlich mal vorbei, eineinhalb Jahre, und wir wissen, was er macht, er bleibt in Paris, und nicht nur ein Jahr, sondern drei Jahre. Und ich glaube, das wird viel Stoff geben dazu und viele Themen im Sommer, weil der Verein steht vor einer Revolution bei den Verantwortlichen und natürlich auch, was der Kader anbelangt.
Ja, wir müssen tatsächlich mit Mbappé, glaube ich, beginnen, weil das eben so eine wichtige Nachricht war, auch wenn das eigentlich ja gar nicht zu dieser Saisonbilanz mit dazu gehört. Ich habe da unglaublich hohe Zahlen gelesen, die herumgehen. Gleichzeitig hat man aber auch gehört, dass das Angebot von Real Madrid jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig viel niedriger gewesen sein soll. Was glaubst du denn, sind die Gründe für Mbappé bei PSG zu bleiben?
Also, laut meiner Informationen hatte sich Mbappé für Real Madrid ursprünglich bis Freitag früh entschieden. Und danach gab es noch ein entscheidendes Treffen mit den Verantwortlichen von Paris Saint-Germain, die ihn umgeschrieben haben und nicht aus finanziellen Gründen, weil er kriegt auf jeden Fall 100 Millionen Euro Netto für die Unterschrift und nicht 300, wie die Spanier behaupten. Und dazu 50 Millionen Netto im Jahr Gehalt. Also so oder so wird er ab dem 1.7. der teuerste Spieler aller Zeiten. Der bestbezahlte. Er bekommt aber unglaublich viel Macht, und das kann man natürlich diskutieren bzw. kritisieren. Er ist 23 Jahre alt, aber er soll nicht nur die Kapitänsbinde bekommen, aber sogar Mitsprache erreicht haben bei der Trainerwahl, die ansteht. Also Pochettino wird wohl morgen Montag endgültig entlassen. Leonardo, der Sportdirektor, ist schon letzte Nacht entlassen worden. Und da hat er auch Mitspracherecht gehabt, weil er mit den Brasilianern gar nicht klarkam. Er kam aber gut klar mit Pochettino nur. Kylian hat gemerkt, dass Pochettino nicht der geeignete Trainer ist, um diese verrückte Kabine im Griff zu haben. Und ich bin mir sicher, dass er auch weiß, wer der nächste Trainer wird, weil ansonsten hätte er nicht für gleich drei Jahre unterschrieben. Drei Jahre ist schon viel. Er redet nicht von zwei plus eins, sondern von drei Jahren bis 2025. Das bedeutet in meinen Augen, dass er sich schon mittelfrissig für Peugeot engagiert, dass er von Real Madrid nichts mehr wissen will. Ich glaube, das ist auch umgekehrt der Fall mittlerweile. Und auch was der Kader betrifft, bei Abgängen, vor allem bei Zugegen, wird Mbappé sein Wort haben. Zum Beispiel wissen wir aus sicheren Quellen, dass er gerne Neymar loshaben möchte und dass er auf der Gegenseite als Nr. 6 Oralien Choumini von Monaco haben möchte.
Das sind ganz schön viele Informationen. Alexi, wie bewertest du denn das als Beobachter, dass ein Spieler, ein junger Spieler, so viel Mitsprache in einem Verein erhält? Gibt es dafür andere Beispiele oder erleben wir das gerade zum ersten Mal?
Ich glaube schon, dass wir es zum ersten Mal erleben, in dieser Masse, in dieser, in dieser, in dieser, so viel Macht zu bekommen, obwohl er, wie gesagt, nur 23 ist, natürlich ist er ein Ausnahme-Stürmer, natürlich ist er momentan vielleicht der Beste der Welt, zusammen mit Karim Benzema und vielleicht noch mit Robert Lewandowski. Aber es ist schon gefährlich, glaube ich, dass ein Spieler so viel Macht bekommt. Es ist für mich das Zeichen, das Parc des St. Jean-Jacques immer noch nicht verstanden hat, dass eigentlich der Verein über jeden Spieler stehen muss. Und das machen die Verantwortlichen weiterhin anders. Erst war Neymar über den Verein, dann Messi und auf einmal Mbappé, der alles entscheiden darf, der eigentlich selber den Kader gestalten möchte. Und stellt man sich vor, Kunte oder warum nicht Joachim Löw unterschreibt, morgen für drei Jahre. Und im Oktober heißt es nach einem 1 zu 1 zuhausegen Salzburg und einer 2 zu 3 Niederlage bei, wer wäre dann Top 4, zum Beispiel Brüge oder sogar, keine Ahnung, Sporting Portugal oder Benfica Lissabon. Ja, was macht man dann? Dann läuft er zum Alkaleifi hoch und sagt, Boss, wir müssen mit Löw aufhören oder mit Kunte. Es geht nicht weiter, er kommt mit uns nicht klar. Und weil Mbappé der Chef ist, heißt es, die Chefs werden sofort seine Wünsche erfüllen. Also das halte ich schon für gefährlich. Auf der anderen Seite, das ist der Hauptgrund, warum Mbappé verlängert hat. In einem halben Jahr haben wir die WM in Katar und das war der größte Wunsch und das größte Ziel der Scheiß in Doha, dass Mbappé während ihrer WM nach wie vor das Paris Saint-Germain-Trikotrik, das war die höchste Priorität und die zweite. Man hat ihm versprochen, dass er bei den Olympischen Spielen in zwei Jahren in Paris auflaufen darf. Das ist ausgemacht worden, zusammen mit Alka Laifi und mit Staatspräsident Emmanuel Macron, weil normalerweise ein Spieler, der die Europamessenschaft bestreiten wird, und das wird der Fall sein in Deutschland, wenn sich natürlich Frankreich qualifiziert, aber dann hätte Mbappé Olympische Spiele plus EM in einem Sommer. Aber das ist ihm versprochen worden und deswegen hat er auch gesagt, ich bleibe doch in Paris, scheinbar wäre ihm dieser Wunschbarkeit nicht unbedingt erfüllt gewesen.
Okay, na gut, das muss PSG letztlich selbst wissen, was man da tut. Ich glaube, da werden wir viele, viele Themen haben, die dann nicht immer mit Sportlichen zu tun haben werden. Jetzt ist das ja eigentlich ein Rückblick auf diese Saison der Ligue 1. Und die erste Frage, die ich allen anderen auch gestellt habe, war eben die nach dem Meister. Da haben wir mit PSG jemanden, der mit 15 Punkten Vorsprung gewonnen hat, der auch letztlich mit seinem 5 zu 0 am letzten Spieltag gegen Metz auch im Abstiegskampf noch ein Wörtchen mitgesprochen hat. Ist es nur die individuelle Qualität, die PSG in diesem Jahr besser gemacht hat oder gibt es noch irgendwelche Erkenntnisse darüber hinaus zu dieser Meisterschaft?
Ich denke, dass die berauffolgenden Mannschaften, vor allem die auf dem Papier heiß gehandelt wurden zum Beginn der Saison, Olympique Lyon, Eismontaco, vor allem, wenn Monaco eine sehr schwache Hinrunde gespielt hat, deswegen auch die Entlassung von Kovac. Nicht zu vergessen, vor genau zwei Monaten war Monaco nur auf Platz 9, mit neun Zählernrückständen auf Platz 3. Und dann gab es neun Siege in Folge, bis auf das 2-2 gestern in Lens. Und deswegen hat man sich dann auf das Podium oder für die Champions League Qualifikation qualifiziert. Aber man war nicht konstant genug. Bilil zum Beispiel vor einem Jahr. Nicht vergessen, Bilil war Meister vor einem Jahr mit einer eingeschworenen Truppe. Und Lyon hat vielleicht die katastrophalste Saison gespielt seit ihm, seit dieser tollen Ära damals zu Beginn des Jahrhunderts. Ja, auf dem Transfermarkt komplett daneben gelegen, bei Schalkeiri, aber leider Gottes auch bei Jérôme Boateng, der komplette Auswahl war und der auch keine Zukunft bei OL hat. Und wenn du solche Mannschaften hast, die keine Konstanz haben, die sich zerfleischen, die keine gute Stimmung in der Kabine haben, dann ist es für Paris ein einfaches Spiel, ohne unbedingt alles zu geben in der Meisterschaft. Und Paris hatte auch das Glück, aber Glück muss man auch können, in der Nachspielzeit vor allem, der Hinrunde, die Spiele zu entscheiden. Ich glaube, ganz ehrlich, Max, wäre heute bei Real oder bei Liverpool gewesen und nicht in Paris. Dann wäre Paris anscheinend mal weder Meister geworden, noch ins Champions League-Finale, Achtelfinale eingezogen. Ich glaube, die wären sogar in der Ruhmphase bereits ausgeschieden, weil er so ein entscheidender Faktor war.
Faszinierend, was ein Spieler dann doch noch ausmachen kann im Teamsportfußball. Dann lass mal hinter PSG gucken, da warten ja dann auch eher so ein bisschen die Überraschungen der Saison. Zählt da für dich Marseille mit dazu?
Ja, auf den ersten Blick schon, weil ich dachte auf dem Papier, dass Lyon und Monaco stärker und besser besetzt sind. Marseille war auch lange im Europapokal, ein bisschen das Halbfinale der Europakonferenz liegt dabei, ausgeschieden gegen Ferne und Rotterdam. Man hat nicht unbedingt spielerisch überzeugt, beziehungsweise war man jetzt im letzten Saison-Titel müde, einsfallslos. Aber gestern war es echt fantastisch, Marseille 4-0 gegen Straßburg, der auch noch nach Europa wollte vor 65.000 Zuschauern. Und das ist schon eine gute Nachricht, dass Marseille direkt qualifiziert ist, weil ich denke, Marseille wäre durch die zwei Quali-Runden im August nicht weitergekommen, weil man da kaum vorbereitet ist, weil man sich da schwer tut gegen Mannschaften, wie zum Beispiel Monaco letzte Saison mit Prag oder Donetsk, an dem man gescheitert ist in den Playoffs, Monaco halte ich dafür besser ausgerichtet. Denn ich denke, dass bis auf die Showmenü werden alle Stammkräfte am Fürstentum bleiben. Mit Jorge Sampaoli hat Marseille natürlich einen zerrückten, aber besessenen Trainer, der die Mannschaft bis in die Haarspitze motivieren kann, auch spielerisch eine Handschrift verpasst hat. Das ist schon sehr interessant. Er hat jetzt vier bis fünf neue Zugehende gefordert. Es wird schwer, seine Wünsche zu erfüllen. Auf der anderen Seite hat Marius jetzt 70 Millionen Euro durch die Champions League-Falli eingenommen. Und auch einen neuen Kontakt für die Liga, wo jeder Verein 16,5 Millionen Euro für die neue Saison bekommt, damit die Liga nicht pleite geht oder die Vereine. Ich denke, dass Marius seinen zweiten Platz im großen und ganzen verdient hat.
Und damit ja auch den End-Sprint gegen Monaco gewonnen. Du hast es vorhin schon mal angedeutet, da würde ich aber gerne noch mal genauer drauf gucken. Niko Kovac wird vor zwei Monaten entlassen auf Rang 9, rangiert Monaco da. Jetzt ist man bis zu einem späten 2 zu 2 eigentlich auf Rang 2 vorgerückt. Jetzt ist es am Ende nur die Qualifikation zur Champions League gewonnen. Was hat sich denn da verändert?
Wenn man Philipp Cremont, der belgische Trainer, mit Niko Kovac vergleicht, Niko Kovac kam mit Fofana, nicht klar, Fofana bildet mit Jormini das Duo vor der Abwehr, also sehr wichtig für den Zusammenhalt und für die Stabilität dieser Elf. Und Niko Kovac hat auch Probleme scheinbar gehabt, also kam nicht wirklich gut klar mit Vincent Bernier, der französische Nationalstürmer. 25 Buden erzielt allein in der Liga in dieser Saison, gestern wieder erfolgreich gewesen und der Kapitän. Und seit Clément das Abend von Kovac übernommen hat, hat Bernier wieder seine beste Form erreicht. Das sind die zwei Schlüsselspieler gewesen, sodass Monaco wieder auf der Siegersstraße zurückkam. Das war wichtig, weil im März hatte der russische Milliardär und eigentlich immer von Monaco gedroht, wenn wir nicht nach Europa gehen, dann werde ich alles ändern. Der Trainer, der Sportdirektor und sogar der Vizepräsident. Und scheinbar nur dieser Letzte wird den Verein verlassen. Man wird auf Kontinuität setzen. Monaco hat seine Automatismen. Und um kein großes oder zu großes Risiko einzugehen, wird man die Mannschaft zusammenhalten, sodass man die besten Chancen hat, die Qualirunden erfolgreich zu bestreiten im August und dann sich für die Grundphase der Champions League zu qualifizieren.
Hat denn der russische Eigentümer noch Zugriff auf Monaco? Ist es keine Abramovic-Situation bei Monaco?
Der Unterschied ist halt, dass Reboloffe seit zehn Jahren nicht mehr nach Russland darf. Da gab es ein Problem mit dem russischen Präsidenten. Und deswegen hat er mit Russland eigentlich nichts mehr zu tun. Er wohnt in Monaco. Laut den französischen Medien und Kollegen hat er es da nicht zu befürchten. Er wird auch seine Position als Monacos Präsident weiterhin ausüben dürfen. Er ist leidenschaftlich dabei. Er will unbedingt, dass Monaco mindestens jedes Saisonende aufs Podium kommt. Und vielleicht nächste Saison Paris Saint-Germain ein bisschen ärgern darf.
Gut, auch da ist natürlich die Frage, wie Mbappé das in Zukunft gestalten wird bei PSG. Dann haben wir, wenn ich jetzt die Tabelle weiter nach unten gehe, Ren und Nizza. Du hast uns noch im März erzählt, Nizza wird in die Champions League kommen. Alexi, was ist da passiert?
Ja, sehr schwache Rückrunde vor allem. Der letzte Spiel-Saison-Titel war sehr enttäuschend. Vielleicht hat man da auf dem Transfermarkt nicht die besten Spieler geholt. Dante ist jetzt 38, man hat mit ihm um ein Jahr verlängert. Kann man eigentlich gut zurück nach seinem Kreuzbandriss. Aber man hat auch gesehen, dass er in die Jahre geht zu Ende der Saison, schwache Leistungen. Eine nach der anderen absolviert. Ich war vor zwei oder zehn Tagen in Nizza gegen Stadtiziane im Stadion, zum ersten Mal dort. Zu Halbzeit lag es schon 0-2. Und dann hat Nizza innerhalb von sieben, acht Minuten drei Treffer gezählt, sodass man die Partie drehen konnte. Genau wie gestern. 0-2 in der Reims, zu Halbzeit. Und dann macht Ony DeLore wieder drei Kisten, sodass man zumindest in der Europakonferenz liegen darf. Aber viel Unruhe um Nizza. Und ich glaube auch, dass es die Tatsache ist, dass Jim Redcliffe sich bei Chelsea angeboten hat, den Verein zu kaufen, dass er bereit war, 1,5 bis 2 Milliarden Euro auszugeben, nachdem er für nur 100 Millionen Euro, in Anführungszeichen natürlich, 100 Millionen Euro Nizza gekauft hat, hat schon für eine gewisse Unruhe gesorgt. An der Cote d'Azur. Auch bei den Spielern, bei den Verantwortlichen. Jetzt heißt es, Redcliffe bleibt, er wird die Mannschaft noch einmal richtig verstärken. Christoph Gelfi, der Trainer, der vor einem Jahr ja viel zur Meisterschaft führte, wird wohl bleiben, auch wenn sein Name bei Paris Saint-Germain kursiert. Aber klar, das fünfte Platz, der nur zu Europakonferenz-League-Qualifikationen führt, ist sehr enttäuschend für Nizza. Und die Rückung war einfach zu schlecht. Auch Dauberberg viel zu wenig gezeigt. Ein Phantom geworden mittlerweile, der dänische Nationalspieler. Wie gesagt, danke, dass du es schon erwähnt hast. Und Guiri war vielleicht der beste League-Anspieler der Hinrunde. Nichts mehr zu sehen, seit Februar kein Tor erzielt, keine Folge gegeben. Also es gibt schon einige Baustellen, Christophe Galtier und die Spieler von Nizza.
Und gehört dann im Umkehrschluss dazu, Rent, auch zu den positiven Überraschungen der Saison? Haben immerhin die zweitbeste Offensive nach Péché mit 82 Toren?
Also die zeigen oder die machen am meisten Spaß in der Liga. Die zeigen ja den attraktivsten Spielstil. Dank Trainer Bruno Genesio, also dem macht es immer Spaß, zuzuschauen. Es gibt nie Null Null, es gibt immer Chancen. Ein toller Verein, der sich gut entwickelt hat, stetig weiterentwickelt hat die letzten Jahren. Das ist schon in der Europa-Konferenz League vor drei Jahren, in der Champions League-Grubenphase gewesen zum ersten Mal. Natürlich war das Podium oder der ganz große Traum, das Ziel war die europäische Qualifikation. Ohne den Ausgleich gestern in der Nachspielzeit bei Lille wäre dann Rhein nur Fünfter geworden und dadurch nicht der Vierter. Also einer wäre dann in der Konferenz League gewesen. Aber es ist eine Mannschaft, die diesen vierten Pass mehr als verdient hat. Mein Auge hätte sogar mehr die Champions League verdient gehabt, aber in den Schlussmomenten hat man ein bisschen geschwächt. Wie bei den in der Lage in Straßburg vor vier, fünf Wochen oder gestern beim 2-2 in Lille, wo der Meister 2021 eigentlich nichts mehr zu gewonnen hatte. Das war schon ein bisschen enttäuschend, aber Rhein hat seinen Auftrag gefüllt. Spielerisch, auch ergebnistechnisch. Ich glaube, auf diese Mannschaft wird es sich lohnen, ein Auge zu werfen in die Europa League und auch in der Meisterschaft, wo wohl einige Spieler heiß begehrt sind.
Dann können wir ja schauen, was da noch passiert. Was gibt es darüber hinaus für Überraschungen in dieser Saison? Oder müssen wir schon zu den Enttäuschungen übergehen?
Ich glaube, Mannschaften, die Bordeaux und St. Etienne verabschiedet haben, bzw. die noch in der Relegation sind, müssen sie natürlich nicht nur enttäuschen, sondern bekommen die Quittung für schlechte Arbeit. Das ist vergleichbar mit der HSV, mit dem Abstieg vor vier Jahren oder vor einer Saison mit Schalke 04 und Werder Bremen. Wenn du schlechte Arbeit hast, bekommst du für das Spiel die Quittung. Das war bei Girona Bordeaux genauso der Fall. Die schlechteste Abwehr ist unter den top europäischen fünf liegen. Ich glaube, bei 85, da musst du mich korrigieren. Aber auf jeden Fall eine Katastrophe. Trotz des 4 zu 2 Sieges ist es noch gestern in Brest. Aber da gab es so viele Probleme, die in den letzten Jahren schon schlecht erwirtschaftet werden. Als Eigentümer, Amerikaner, die sich nicht wirklich identifiziert haben mit dem Verein, die mehr Geld verdienen wollten, als die Mannschaft sorgfältig und strukturiert zu verstärken. Und Saint-Étienne genauso. Hätte gestern Saint-Étienne in Norden nicht ausgeglichen, kurz vor Schluss wäre er in die Grünen. Der noch Rekordmeister ist, zusammen mit PSG mit zehn Meistertiteln, heute auch in der Zweiten Liga. Und dann dieses Ausgleich dürfen die die Stefanoa zwei Relegationsspielen bestreiten gegen die ehemalige Mannschaft von Giroud, Agios Serra. Im Kampf um den Aufstieg oder den Klassenerhalt in der Liga. Und auch wichtig für dich, für die kommende Saison bei Rauschenfunk, die Liga ist umso dramatischer, weil wir ab 2023, 2025 nur noch 18 Mannschaften haben werden. Das heißt, dass in der kommenden Saison keine Relegationsspiele anstehen, sondern dass vier Mannschaften aus der Liga direkt absteigen und nur zwei aufsteigen dürfen.
Das wird allerdings interessant. Ja, woher kommt die Reduzierung? Warum will man das?
Das war zu der Zeit vor einem Jahr, als die Super League im Gespräch war. Natürlich wird die Champions League aufgestockt, ein bisschen ab 2024. Aber man hat auch gemerkt, dass wenn man ein bisschen die Liga reduziert, dass die vielleicht ein bisschen konkurrenzfähiger wird, weil man hat es wieder in dieser Saison festgestellt, Mannschaften wie Metz, Bordeaux, Saint-Étienne, oder sogar Lorient oder Troyes sind Mannschaften, die sich schwer tun in der Liga 1. Deswegen haben wir uns an die Bundesliga angeboten. Man hat schon vor zwei Jahren den Liga-Pokal abgeschafft. Damit man auch einen entspannteren Spielplan hat. In fünf, sechs Jahren, wenn die Champions League von 27 bis 2030 noch mal aufgestoppt wird, mit vielleicht noch mehr Spielen, dann wird man auf 16 Mannschaften in der Liga ankommen.
Interessante Entwicklung. Aber die Diskussion gibt es ja durchaus auch noch in anderen Ligen, die 20er-Ligen zu reduzieren. Welche Spieler waren denn in der Saison so richtige Entdeckungen? Wenn ich jetzt mal zum Beispiel auf die Torschützenliste gucke, dann haben wir natürlich neben Mbappé, der irgendwie häufiger vorkommt in diesem Segment, habe ich das Gefühl, Ben Yedet, den du schon angesprochen hast, mit 25 Treffern, aber auch Martin Therrien von Rennes mit 21, Moussa Dembélé von Lyon mit 21 Treffern. Aber das sind ja die Stürmer, die einem immer am ehesten auffallen. Darüber hinaus bin ich völlig hilflos, Alexi. Also hilf mir, welche Spieler-Namen sind besonders interessant und sind in Erscheinung getreten in dieser Saison?
Erst einmal möchte ich feststellen und mitteilen, dass die Trojegaliste von den rein französischen Stürmern dominiert wurden. Ich glaube, die ersten 5, 6 sind reine Franzosen. Die hast du schon erwähnt mit Thierry, mit Dembélé und so weiter. De Loro auch mit 18 Treffern an seinem Dreierpark gestern. Auch wenn er seit Kurzem für die algräische Nationalmannschaft spielt. Jetzt hatte ich was vergessen. Thierry ist keine Entdeckung, weil er sich schon bei der Olympiaklinie gezeigt hat. Aber da hatte er sich, oder hatte Schwierigkeiten, sich durchzusetzen. Trotzdem hat er es in dieser Saison durchbrucht. Er hat schon mal einen Anruf von wie jeder schon bekommen. Vielleicht für die Nationalmannschaft. Aber da ist die Konkurrenz so groß, dass es sehr schwer für ihn werden wird. Aber so von seinem Spielstil her, von seiner Eleganz am Ball, den könnte ich mir schon sehr gut in der Bundesliga vorstellen. Auch wenn er sich in der Britannia sehr wohlfühlt. Da bin ich schon sehr überrascht, dass er so viele Treffer als dieser hat. Er ist der einzige Lichtblick bei den Lyonais in dieser traurigen Spielzeit. Eigentlich sagt man über Dembele in Frankreich, er ist ein guter Schwimmer, aber er hat keine Füße. Und in dieser Saison war er ein bisschen effizienter vom generischen Tor. Letzte Saison noch in der zweiten Saisonhälfte bei Atlético de Madrid ausgeliehen. Er hat überhaupt keinen Fuß gefasst. Aber jetzt nach seiner erfolgreichen Spielzeit wird er wieder heiß begehrt. Also schon eine gewisse Überraschung, auch wenn er in Frankreich bekannt ist. Und da werde ich natürlich gespannt, wer von den Jugendtalenten in der Liga in dieser Saison in die Bundesliga wechseln werden. Es ist ja eine Tendenz, eine Mode gewesen in den letzten Jahren. Diese tolle Mode wird sich, glaube ich, fortsetzen. Man hat ja schon den jungen Antonika Si von Straßburg, der Name eins geht, der linksverteidiger, aber natürlich Randale, fantastischer Vorname, Colomoni, der zu der Frankfurter Eintracht wechselt und gleich in die Champions League ran darf. Und wo ich sage, da kommt es auch Navid Vor, ein Nachfolger für Erling Haaland als Nr. 9. Und da spielt, glaube ich, nicht nur Sebastien Allende Rolle, sondern der junge Stürmer Hugo Echidicke von Stadranz. Also da bin ich gespannt, wie es weitergeht.
Ja, da können wir ja gespannt sein, haben wir ja schon mal thematisiert, dass da wirklich sehr, sehr viel Talent aus der Liga schon rübergekommen ist in die Bundesliga. Welche Trainer waren denn wichtig? Du hast vorhin schon ein paar Namen genannt, aber lass mal beginnen, wer war für dich der Trainer der Saison?
Schwierige Frage, weil Mannschaften wie Rennes und Schwarzburg, die eigentlich bis zum Schluss im Kampf um Europa dabei waren, bzw. sich rein qualifiziert, Schwarzburg klar gescheitert, aber die hätten wir zum Beispiel nicht erwartet. Aber dort spielt oder trainiert Julien Stéphan, junger französischer moderner Trainer. Er ist der Sohn vom Co-Trainer der Nationalmannschaft. Er prägt ein modernes Spiel mit viel Gegenpressing. Er schaut sich immer an die Bundesliga an. Er hat ziemlich viel Erfolg gehabt. Sein Name wird auch immer wieder gehört bei Olympique Lyon, weil man so dort einen Nachfolger für Peter Boss, der überhaupt nicht erfolgreich war, bzw. genauso erfolgreich wie früher in Dortmund oder Leberkusen, wenn du weißt, was ich meine. Das Marius Yopochekino, nicht erwähnen will, glaube ich, ist normal. Er hat in meinen Augen die Mannschaft keinen Zentimeter weitergebracht in den 18 Monaten, wo er in Paris Saint-Germain ist. Malai ist noch nicht entlassen zu dieser Uhrzeit. Könnte aber was werden. Und natürlich der Trainer von Rhein, wie gesagt, Dank Bruno Genesio, hat Rhein eine affraktive Spielweise gezeigt, hat seinen Fans begeistert. Aber nicht nur seine eigenen Fans. Also, Rhein zu zuschauen ist eine Augenweide. Und das ist der Verdienst von Bruno Genesio. Jorge Sampaoli zu erwähnen von so einer Spielweise ist viel schwieriger, weil er eher ein Vulkan ist als ein Top-Top-Top-Trainer, wie der gute Pep sagt. Und der Trainer von Monaco, Philipp Clément, ihn zu analysieren nach einem halben Jahr, ich glaube, ein bisschen zu früh. Aber er hatte schon Paris Saint-Germain gejagert in der Champions League mit Brügge in der ersten Saisonhälfte, in der Champions League-Hogenphase, auch Leipzig gejagert, auch Manchester City. Und den könnte man, glaube ich, in der nächsten Saison besser beurteilen. Also Genesio und Stephane für mich, die zwei Trainer, die die beste Arbeit erledigt haben in der Liga.
Wie würdest du jetzt im Nachhinein die Saison von Christophe Galtier einordnen, der ja zu Nizza gewechselt ist?
Ja, eine Drei-Plus. Also gut, aber mit einem Fall Malgeschmack, weil die ersten zwei Saison-Titel waren richtig gut, ganz klar. Man war lange auf Chemnitzekurs, man war sehr lange auf Platz zwei. Man hat das Pokalfinale erreicht, aber man hat das Pokalfinale verloren gegen den FC Nord, obwohl man favorit war. Und Nizza hat dieses Spiel gar nicht bestritten. Man hat keinen Fußballgesinn von Nizza im Pokalfinale, und das war schon sehr, sehr frustrierend. Und dann, wie gesagt, die letzten Spieltage kaum erfolgreich gewesen. Zwar defensiv solide agiert, aber nach vorne ging sehr wenig los. Also, bis auf diese zwei Spiele, die ich vorher erwähnt habe. Beim Spiel gegen Santé-Tier und gestern in der Reims hat Nizza so gut wie nie mehr als ein Tor erzählt. Und ich hoffe, dass Galtier Nizza bleibt. Ich glaube, er kann nächste Saison mehr zeigen. Aber wie gesagt, gut. Gute erste Saison, weil es ist nicht einfach, von Ligatour nach Nizza zu wechseln, von einer Meistermannschaft, zu einer Mannschaft, die nicht mehr im Europa-Pokal dabei ist, aber keinerfalls dabei geschmackt, weil das Ende der Saison relativ holprig verlief.
Und dann kannst du jetzt in die Glaskugel gucken, lieber Alexi. Wer wird denn in der nächsten Saison für Furore sorgen? Vielleicht sogar eine Mannschaft, die jetzt das internationale Geschäft verpasst hat. Und deswegen wird ja wahrscheinlich relativ angespannt werden, die Situation in der nächsten Saison mit den vier Absteigern. Vielleicht kann da jemand von profitieren und anderen Schnüppchen schlagen?
Ich glaube, eine Mannschaft, die bestens strukturiert ist oder war, vielleicht das modernste und schönste Stadion der Liga hat, das beste Jugendzentrum, weil dort Spieler wie Kaim Benzema, Atem Ben Affar, ausgebildet wurden. Ich rede natürlich von Oland Biklion. Der kommt in der Saison nicht im Europa-Bukal dabei, erneut. Nicht in der Champions League vorliegen, das war das Hauptziel. Und wenn sich die Millionäre, und das hat der Präsident Jean-Michel Olaß erwähnt, man wird schon gewisse Mittel haben, weil man hat jetzt neue Aktionäre in dem Verein, sodass man sich trotzdem klug verstärken kann und punktuell. Aber dass man dann keine Spiele unter der Woche hat, kann schon zum Vorteil werden. Ich will mal einen vernünftigen Trainer endlich mal erholen wieder und eine spartkräftige Mannschaft aufbauen und die Sorgenkinder in dem jetzigen Kader verkaufen können und loshaben können, damit wieder bessere Stimmung herrscht, also wenn dann, oder ein bisschen jung, aber das Schwarzburg zum Beispiel erneut überrascht, wird schon schwer. Die einzige Chance ist, dass der Julian Stefan bleibt, aber wie gesagt, er ist von Jung, Heiß und Worben und ich denke, auf Rhein ist wieder Verlass, weil es eine Mannschaft, die auf Kontinuität setzt und in der Lage ist, auch wieder für Überraschung zu sorgen, er sein wird.
Na dann werden wir doch mal gucken. Und dann die Abschlussfrage, welche Anekdoten gibt es denn aus dieser Ligue 1 Saison, wo du sagst, wenn ich dich in fünf Jahren anspreche, weißt du noch, damals in der Saison, in der MAP seinen Vertrag unterschrieben hat und PSG quasi zum Kylian Mbappé-Filialclub wurde, an was wirst du dich denn darüber hinaus noch erinnern, an dieser Ligue 1 Saison?
Ja, dass es halt viele verrückte Spiele gab, aber natürlich bleibt in Erinnerung in der Hinrunde diese zu oft gesehenen Spielerbrüchen in Nizza, in Lyon, in Angers gegen Marseille. Das war schon sehr traurig, weil man hatte die Pandemie, es war so oft oder monatelang Spiele unter Aufschluss der Öffentlichkeit, Geisterspiele, wie man so schön sagt, und danach wieder Spiele um Zuschauer aus disziplinarischen Gründen. Und ich hoffe, dass wir solche Szenen nicht mehr sehen werden. Das halte ich für schwierig, weil Fankai ist immer ein heißes Pflaster im Punkt der Fußball, und das hat mich schon traurig gemacht, in der Hinrunde immer wieder Spiele kommentieren zu dürfen, wo nach drei Minuten nichts mehr los war, weil die Spieler alle in der Kabine waren, weil das Spiel abgebrochen wurde und nicht mehr angepfiffen. Und die Verantwortlichen der Liga nicht in der Lage waren, das Spiel erst nach zwei Stunden abzubrechen und nicht schnell Konsequenzen zu treffen. Und ich hoffe, das kommt nicht mehr wieder vor, aber da habe ich leider meine Bedenken. Positiv betrachtet muss man fast schon MBP erwähnen. Man dachte, vor allem nach dem Außenreal, er kann nur noch dorthin wechseln. Aber ich denke persönlich, warum er verlängert hat, ich glaube, er kann sich, die PSG-Fans können sich bei Karim Benzema belangen. Hätte dieser positiv verrückte Stürmer von Real nicht dermaßen oft getroffen in den letzten Wochen, wäre natürlich Real nicht im Finale. Und dann hat MBP jetzt gecheckt, festgestellt, warum soll ich dorthin wechseln, gewinnt eh alles ohne mich. Und wenn ich in Paris bleibe und gewinne dort zum ersten Mal die Champions League in der Vereinsgeschichte, dann werde ich ein richtiger Held. Und das glaube ich in seinen Augen, auch in seinem Kopf. Der Kilian ist auch ein sehr wichtiges Argument.
Spannend. Nimmt er den steinigen Weg? Da bin ich ja sehr gespannt, wie der verlaufen wird. Alexi, ich danke dir sehr herzlich. Danke nicht nur jetzt für diese Zusammenfassung, sondern auch für all deine Unterstützung während dieser Saison. Na ja, Urlaub mehr oder weniger. Und ebenfalls natürlich danke an David Frangier, der Paul Lévoix, dem wir ja hier auch häufiger zur Ligue 1 gehört haben. Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Abonniert gerne auch die Schlusskonferenz. Da kommt in Kürze der Rasenfunk Royale raus. Der ausführliche Rutschblick auf die Männer Bundesliga mit je einem Gast pro Verein plus noch einzelnen Segmenten zu Schiedsrichtern, Torhütern, Taktik und den Rasenfunk erscheint am Mittwoch und unterstützt gerne den Rasenfunk finanziell. Wir sind werbe-, paywall- und sponsorenfrei. Allein eure freiwilligen Zahlungen halten dieses Projekt hier am Laufen. Wie ihr uns unterstützen könnt, erfahrt ihr auf rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. In diesem Sinne habt eine gute Zeit, bleibt gesund, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und dann hören wir uns hoffentlich bald wieder hier im Rasenfunk. Macht es gut, bis bald, bleibt gesund, ciao.